Good morning, everyone.
Seeing that board members are now present, Brooks, will you please call the roll to establish
the quorum?
Good morning.
President Darlin-Hammond.
Here.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Here.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Here.
Member Olken.
Vice President Williams.
Here.
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Here.
Member Porter.
Member Rodriguez.
Here.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Everyone's present.
All right.
In closed session, the board discussed and took action on the following legal matters,
MSCV state.
Now I want to ask for the public comment slide to be put on the screen so that we can take
up our waiver consent items.
There we go.
The waiver consent items are waivers W-1 through 6, and we will now open the phone line for
public comment queue.
Let's take a moment.
People who want to make comments should call into the number listed on the slide and use
the participant access code.
Remember to turn down the volume of your computer or live webcast to avoid background echoes,
and public comments are one minute.
Is there any public comment?
There are currently no callers in the queue for public comment, so that concludes public
comment for W-1 through W-6.
Okay.
With that, without public comment, is there a motion to pass these waiver items?
Yes.
Thank you.
And a second?
I'll second it.
Thank you.
We'll now hold a roll call vote.
Brooks, please call the roll.
President Darling-Hammond.
Yes.
Aye.
Member Escobedo.
Yes.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Member Lewis.
Yes.
Member McQuillan.
Member Olken.
Yes.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Yes.
Member Porter.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Motion carries unanimously.
Thank you.
We're now going to move to Item 12.
Item 12 is the California Assessment of Student Performance and Progress System and the English
Language Proficiency Assessments for California.
We have the request for approval of the proposed addendum to the high-level test design for
the California Spanish Assessments for California.
the California Spanish Assessments, the proposed California Spanish Assessment Revised Blueprint,
the proposed Revised California Spanish Assessment General Achievement Level Descriptors, and
proposed Score Reporting Structure, the 2021-22 results for the California Assessment of Student
Performance and Progress System, and the English Language Proficiency Assessments for California,
and we call this the Mega Assessment Item.
And CDE recommends that we approve the proposed addendum to the high-level test design, the
proposed Revised Blueprint for the California Spanish Assessment, and the proposed Score
Reporting Structure for the California Spanish Assessment.
This item will be presented by Cheryl Cotton and Mao Vang of the CDE.
Cheryl, can you please begin?
Good morning.
Superintendent Thurmond, President Darling-Hammond, Vice President Glover-Woods, and board members.
I'm Cheryl Cotton, Deputy Superintendent at the Instruction, Measurement, and Administration
Branch.
To assist with this item today, I have Dr. Mao Vang, Director of Assessment, Development,
and Administration Division, to co-present.
The item before you today is an action and information item.
Thank you.
Today's presentation will cover the following.
Three action items for approval regarding the California Spanish Assessment.
Then we'll go over the additional assessment updates for the California Assessment of Student
Performance and Progress, or the CASP, and the English Language Proficiency Assessment
for California, the LPAC.
And finally, we will return to the CDE's recommendation for State Board of Education action.
At this time, I will provide an overview of the California Department of Education's
recommendations for approval.
Next slide, please.
Thank you.
The California Department of Education recommends that the California State Board of Education
approve the following.
Proposed addendum to the high-level test design for the California Spanish Assessment, including
the proposed Revised Spanish Assessment General Achievement Level Descriptors in Attachment
2, the proposed California Spanish Assessment Revised Blueprint in Attachment 3, and the
proposed Spanish Assessment Score Reporting Structure as provided in this item.
Now I will have Mao Vang present the remainder of this item.
Thank you.
Good morning, Superintendent Thurmond, President Darling-Hammond, Vice President Glover-Woods,
and Board Members.
As Cheryl mentioned, I'm Mao Vang, Director of the Assessment Development and Administration
Division at the Department of Education.
And I will discuss the proposed actions regarding our California Spanish Assessment.
So, the intent of the California Assessment per Education Code, Section 606405C, the superintendent
is to develop a primary language assessment that would support, in part, for the seal,
the state seal of biliteracy.
And then we also have the Education Code, Section 51461, has requirements that support
the state seal of biliteracy, which is the law that identifies the requirements that
support that education code.
And one of the requirements is for students to pass an assessment that, at a minimum,
assesses speaking, reading, writing, and another language, in another language, in
addition to English.
So, when the development of the California Spanish Assessment began, funds were limited,
and the speaking and writing constructive response items were not developed at that
time.
So, students were unable to use the results of the California Spanish Assessment to meet
the one criterion for attaining the state seal of biliteracy.
So, last November, 2021, the California State Board of Education did approve a new contract
that included the development of the speaking and the expansion of the writing of this
particular test.
So, the proposed addendum to the California Spanish Assessment high-level test design
is what we'll cover next.
This addendum articulates how the test design presented in the 2016 high-level test design
for California Spanish Assessment has been updated to include the addition of the speaking
domain and the expansion of the writing domain.
So, the team that worked on this addendum was done with input from the CASP technical
advisory group, the assessment interest holder group, and Dr. Kenji Hakuta, who is a professor
emeritus at Stanford, and Dr. Guadalupe Valdez, also a professor at Stanford University.
And we will continue to meet and work with the various interest holders as we expand
the speaking domain, as we develop the speaking domain and expand the writing domain.
So, next I'll cover the California Spanish Test General Achievement Level Descriptors.
These provide generic descriptions of student performance level expectations across three
levels.
Once those are approved, they will be used to set grade level or grade span specific
achievement level descriptors and develop the reporting achievement level descriptors
that describe levels of performance to educators, students, and parents or guardians.
And these revisions include the expansion of, again, the California Spanish Assessment
domains with the addition of the speaking to the general level achievement level descriptors
and the removal of the word mechanics from the descriptor because the writing domain
will be fully assessed once operational.
Now I'll go over the revised California Spanish Assessment Blueprint, which includes updates
to the 2017 blueprint that the State Board of Education approved.
And it provides the proposed number of items and points for the addition of speaking and
the expansion of the writing in grades three through eight and high school.
So, the number of items and points are subject to revisions on the basis of statistical analyses
of the new writing and speaking constructed response items after first field test and
the first operational uses.
And these are aligned with the California Common Core State Standards in Espanol as
translated and linguistically augmented versions of the, which are translated and
linguistically augmented versions of the California Common Core State Standards for
English language arts and literacy.
And now I'll go over the proposed California Spanish Assessment score reporting structure.
So, the proposed reporting structure is included in the item and it has an overall scale score
with three achievement levels, reading, in the domains of reading, writing, listening,
and speaking.
Then after the first operational administration in 2024-25, data will be used to evaluate
the reliability of the score reporting structure and additional analyses will be conducted
to determine whether we have enough items to support four achievement levels.
In our next steps, once the State Board of Education approves these proposed recommendations,
that each action will play a very critical part of us moving forward in the development
of the speaking and the writing constructed response items to the operational administration
of the California Spanish Assessment targeted to be in the 2024-25 school year.
And that brings us to some additional, again, this is the assessment mega item, so we have
multiple topics to bring to you.
And now I will cover the additional program updates that, or highlight the additional
program updates that might be of interest to you.
We will share the science resources that are in the Tools for Teachers and then I'll walk
through the student score reports, redesign goals and timelines that we have in the works.
And then we'll go over the public release of the 21-22 CASP and ALPAC test results that
just occurred a couple weeks ago.
And the science resources that are being built in the Tools for Teachers, just want to share
that in July, the California Department of Education continued to conduct our workshops
to help California educators develop additional science resources for kindergarten through
high school for the Tools for Teachers website.
And this is built mainly with workshop participants who are educators and they're involved as
team leads and developers and then our California science staff or assessment staff are served
as trainers and coaches.
And these additional resources are peer reviewed and posted, built by California educators
for California educators for a total of 70 science formative assessment resources that
are available to all public school educators in the Tools for Teachers.
Another highlight is the redesign of the 23-24 California assessment of student performance
and progress or CASP in our English language proficiency assessments for California or ALPAC.
The student score reports, here are our redesign goals of this process is to improve the reporting
of the test results provided to students and parents or guardians that include actionable
item information, excuse me, and then also to provide students and parents or guardians
with timely access to their test results while minimizing the distribution effort for local
educational agencies.
The high level timeline is provided in that just high level wise from September through
January of this school year, ETS, our assessment contractor, is in the process of developing
concept design options and will conduct formal focus groups and other more informal focus
groups as well.
As of right now, I'm at the California Educational Research Association Conference and we will
be doing a couple focus groups from our conference participants about the same topic.
And then in February through June, ETS will prepare mock-ups for CDE to get approval from
the various interest holders and this is a time where our SBE members could provide
some input and have time to weigh in before the final mock-ups are done.
And then from July to August, ETS and the CDE will collaborate and use our feedback
from the various interest holders and the design options that are provided and prepare
reports planned for our September board meeting.
And then in September, we plan to bring to the State Board of Education the recommendation
for the student score report revisions for approval at that time.
Now I will go over the public release of our CASP and ALPAC results.
Okay, so the 21-22 CASP and ALPAC results were released to the public on Monday, October
24th of this year.
These are the academic and English language proficiency assessments that we use as a state
to meet state and federal requirements.
One thing I'd like to highlight here, before I go into all the assessments results, I'd
just like to provide a little bit of context and background here that we do have one more
assessment, the California Alternate Assessment for Science, that you approved the threshold
scores in September.
Those results will be released in December because we need more time to work on those
reporting of those results.
So just some background information to remind us that the 22-22 administration really marked
the return to full statewide administration for the CASP since 2019.
And remember that in 2019-20, many schools quickly turned to remote learning after the
discovery of the COVID-19 virus in California.
And then, of course, that year, the U.S. Department of Education waived all testing requirements,
so there is no CASP or CASP results that year.
And then in 2020-21, to further prevent the spread of the virus even before the development
and widespread distribution and use of vaccines, most students continued learning remotely
from home for most of the year.
So during that year, local educational agencies that were unable to administer our statewide
assessments, because it was not a viable option due to the factors that are related to the
COVID-19 pandemic, were allowed the option to use locally selected assessments that met
certain criteria that the Board approved to assess students' learning in English Language
Arts and Mathematics.
So when comparing results, the 2021-22 results to results prior to the pandemic, we must
consider the continued impact of the pandemic on students, families, and educators in the
21-22 school year.
And the context just surrounding the teaching and learning in the 21 and 22 years was quite
different and unique than in many LEAs when we look at the context surrounding teaching
and learning in the 2018-19 or prior, before the pandemic.
So the data from the 21-22 spring administrations should be considered baseline data for measuring
student progress going forward due to those challenges that are presented by the pandemic.
And the assessment results, again, just reminding people that are the really one measure of
student achievement or proficiency in the case of LPAC, it should always be used in
conjunction with other data and measures in making instructional or program decisions.
With that, I will go over our SPAC.
There stands for the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium.
We use the English Language Arts or ELA and math assessments from the consortium.
And here I will highlight our statewide results in all tested grades, 3 through 8 and 11.
We see that in all students, we showed that 47% of students met or exceeded standards in
English Language Arts or ELA there.
And that we also showed the 2019, the last year prior to the pandemic, which is a four percentage
point decrease from 2019, so from 51 to 47.
And in mathematics, the decrease appears slightly larger with 33% of students meeting or exceeding
standards in 2022, which is a seven percentage point decrease from 2019.
And then we have the same comparisons in grades 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 and high school grade 11.
And then we also look at the percent of students meeting or exceeding, who met or exceeded
standards by race or ethnicity.
And when results are broken down by race or ethnicity, all student groups show decreases
from 2019 in the percent of students who met or exceeded standards as well.
And the groups that we look at are the American Indian or Alaska Native, Asian, Black or African
American, Filipino, Hispanic or Latino, Native Hawaiian or Pacific Islander, White, and two or
more races.
So each of these have, again, comparing the 2019 through the 22 results for English Language
Arts and Mathematics.
And then we also look at the percent of students who met or exceeded standards by gender and
ethnicity in the 2020-21 program, purely just to fit all this on the slide for you.
The groups are, again, we see similar declines because if the overall, there were declines,
then, of course, any of the groups would show some decline as well.
And the results here for the other groups, student groups, also show decreases from the
in the percent of students who met or exceeded standards,
with the exception of ELA for students with disabilities,
when we have the 16 to 16 there in terms of the percent,
in English language arts across the board.
So the groups that we, as I mentioned,
also disaggregated the data for here at a high level
are female by female, male, economically disadvantaged,
English learner, students with disabilities,
students who have at least a family member in the military,
and then students whose families are homeless,
and then students who are foster youth.
However, although all these declines or decreases
across almost all groups in English language arts and math,
there are some early signs of learning recovery.
I'd just like to share that we did have our ETS,
our assessment contractor,
conducted a two-year matched cohort analysis
to explore how much learning increased
for the same group of students at two points in time,
between 2020-21 and 2021-22.
And remember that in the spring of 2021,
only about 25% of students in grades three through eight
and 11, or about 740,000, yes, 740,000 students
participated in the Smarter Balanced summative assessments
for English language arts and mathematics.
And in that analysis, or the analysis of that cohort,
again, looking at the same students
who took the test in 2021,
and comparing their results to 22,
show a steeper than normal achievement gains
at most grade levels,
which is really a hopeful sign
that the state's investments in accelerating learning
may be paying off.
We are providing a sample matched cohort chart
for mathematics in grades six to seven
to highlight the mean scale scores
for the 2020-21 grade six matched cohort
and their results in grade seven in 2021-22.
And the starting point here is kind of small,
but I hope you can see that the starting point was 2495
and the predicted scale score was 2512.
And the observed was 2521,
which was nine scale score points greater than predicted.
So this rate of change for this cohort
was 52% greater in mathematics
than would have been expected
for a similar pre-pandemic group of students,
that is students who were in the 2017-18
with similar grades six mean scale scores
and their grade seven mean scale scores
for the 2018-19 year.
So additional match cohort analysis
for all the available grades
can be found in the interpretation guide
that we have attached to this item.
And it's called the interpretation guide
to the 2021-22 statewide assessment results.
So the increases here in a match cohort of students scores
in English language arts and mathematics
between these two years
suggest that learning recovery may already be underway
as going in the right direction.
And while there's still so much more to be done,
of course, in helping students excel
and thrive in the coming years,
this is certainly a positive sign.
Then I will cover the rest of the other assessments
that are under CASP.
It's a fairly large program.
So here we have the California alternate assessments
or CAAs for English language arts and mathematics.
There are three achievement levels
for this particular assessment.
And it is for the students
with the most significant cognitive disabilities
whose individualized education program team
has designated that they use an alternate assessment
on the statewide summative assessments.
So the performance on the California alternate assessments
for English language arts and mathematics
are shown with slight decreases from 2019 also.
And the statewide results for all tested grades
show that 14% of students met standards in ELA,
a 2% decrease from the 2019 year.
And then in the California alternate assessments
for mathematics, we see a similar decrease
from pre-pandemic numbers with a percentage,
8% of students scoring at level three,
which is the highest level of understanding.
And then a 2%, which is a 2% decrease from 2019 also.
And then we also provide the other summaries
for grades three, four, five, six, seven, eight,
and grade 11 for high school.
And then next I will cover
the California science test or CAST.
Students in grades five, eight,
and once in high school,
take the CAST in those particular grades.
So students' scores or performance
were generally consistent with pre-pandemic levels
with a small increase for some groups in some grades
and small decreases in others.
However, we're just providing
the high-level grade level here for you.
And the statewide results in all test of grades here
show 29% of students met or exceeded standards in 2022,
with about one percentage point change from 29.
And then again, the grades are provided there also.
For the California Spanish assessment,
the performance on this particular test,
which is an optional assessment,
is generally consistent with the pre-pandemic.
2019 was the first year of this assessment.
And it was the first operational administration.
So when comparing the average score reporting ranges
by grade, we saw slight decreases
in grades three, four, five, seven, and 11,
and the remaining grades stayed the same.
And then moving on to the summative LPAC,
the SART Language Proficiency Test,
the percent of students meeting overall performance
level four by grade.
And level four is the cutoff for students
who can use it as one,
to meet one of the criteria for reclassification.
So we showed that when compared to...
So overall, when compared to the...
We did provide all three years, 2019 and 2021,
not all three, but not the 2020.
But for LPAC, although there was the suspension in 2020,
and then there's the flexibility in 2021 forecast,
there was no flexibility for LPAC.
So pretty much we did test about 89% of students
in 2021 as well.
So we're providing all three years of results
for your reference here.
And when compared to the school year ending
in the 2022 there, the percentage of students
meeting the overall performance level four
was approximately 16% compared to 14 in 2021.
And then 16 in 2020, 2019.
And this is the level again, needed to be eligible
for reclassification.
Just to give you an overall, the 2021, 22,
in that particular year, last year,
the number of identified English learners
who took the summative LPAC was around one million,
a little bit over one million,
which is a slight increase of 4.6% from the 2021 year
when we only tested about 89% of the students.
And then overall, most students or grade groups here,
there were slight increases or slight decreases, excuse me,
or stay the same from 2019,
which is again, the last year before the pandemic
compared to our 2022 year,
with the exception of grades six through eight,
which is slight, there was slight increases there
in meeting overall performance level four.
And these are, in this particular slide,
we have the summative, the 2021, 22 summative,
LPAC, which is the percent of students
at each performance level by grade for your reference.
Remember that last year,
we conducted the alternate LPAC operational field test.
The results were used to create the summative
alternate LPAC results to meet that requirement.
And these are the first reported results
for this particular assessment,
which again, is based on that operational field test
that we did last year.
And in the 2021, 22 year,
the number of eligible students or English learners
who took the summative alternate LPAC was around 16,
a little bit over 16,000.
And again, this is the students who are English learners
who also are students
with the most significant cognitive disabilities.
So this is about approximately 29% of the students
who test and met an overall level three.
And the alternate assessments, we have three levels.
And this overall level three,
or considered fluent English proficient,
are now eligible for reclassification as well.
I would just wanna make one little note
that the percentages may not all add up to 100
for each grade level or a grade span
due to rounding for the summative alternate LPAC
and the initial LPAC results.
So wanted to point that out.
And then for the initial LPAC,
this is the test where students who have a home language
other than English were first enrolled
in our California schools.
And they take the LPAC, the initial LPAC for the first time
to identify whether they're initially fluent
or they are English learners
who would need additional services.
In last year, the number of students
who took the initial LPAC was a little bit over 200,000.
And 200,000, 208,585 to be exact.
And that was about 84% of students who were administered,
oh, about 84% of the students who were administered
this initial LPAC are identified as English learners.
And then only about 16% of the students
who took this initial LPAC met the state definition
of English language proficient
by receiving an overall scale score,
overall score level, performance level of three
or initial fluent English proficient, as I mentioned,
and are not required to receive English program or services.
And I'm sure that was a lot,
but I wanted to provide you a little bit more information
that covers all the highlights of each of the assessments
that we administer this past year
that are available at this point in time
and for our public release.
The location for the public web reports
is at this website that I've provided and also available.
And it includes the summary reports by school,
by district, by county and statewide levels
for all students and student groups.
And then it also allows for comparisons or change over time.
We also have these performance trend reports
by student group and the research files.
Researchers can or anybody out there can take all the data
that are available on the public reporting site
and provide it in these research files
that you could download and create other groups or looks
by your particular school or region or area that by school,
by district, by county, by student groups.
So it's a very much used public reporting site
for our California also researchers
as well as the general public.
And then we do, like I mentioned,
we did attach the interpretation guide
to the 2021-22 statewide assessment results
for you in this item.
And hopefully you will refer to that
for more information on our public release.
And then to help with going through our public release,
we have a public website reporting site.
Sometimes there's just so much information.
Where do you start?
We have these short quick reference guides
to our public reporting website.
And it provides you a quick overview of where to begin.
If you wanna just review overall results, you go here.
These are the steps you do.
If you wanna compare test results,
these are the steps you take.
And then how to view change over time for test results.
We also have a little how-to.
These are little one-pager quick reference guides.
And then we also have the,
how to view this test results by various student groups
and how to change and filter those groups.
And again, a little one-pager to help
and guide you along with that.
And with that, that brings us to the end
of our presentation and following,
again, reminding you to follow us
on Twitter at a CDE assessments.
And then if you have any questions
or I'll stop right here.
And turn it back to our, oh, sorry.
And then I will read our California recommendations.
I'm not sure if or President,
you want me to stop here for any questions
or go through that first.
You can certainly read the recommendation.
And then what we're gonna do is take any clarifying questions
and then we'll go to public comment.
Thank you.
So just as,
just to go over the CDE recommendation for approval again,
the California Department of Education recommends
that the California State Board of Education
approve the following,
the proposed addendum to the high-level test design
for the California Spanish assessment,
including the proposed revised
California Spanish assessment,
general achievement level descriptors and attachment two.
The proposed California Spanish assessment
revised blueprint and attachment three.
And the proposed California Spanish assessment
score reporting structure.
And with that, I will turn it back to you.
Can you put up the public comment slide?
There we go.
So we're gonna open the phone line
for the public comment queue.
And members of the public that are wishing
to provide comment on this item can do so
by calling the telephone number,
using the access code on the slide that is shown now.
And then while we're waiting,
I wanna ask our liaison member, Roscoe Gonzalez,
if she has any initial comments before me,
then we'll see if there are any clarifying questions
from the board.
And then we'll go to the public comment
and come back for discussion.
Member Roscoe Gonzalez.
Hello, I'm going to go ahead and pull it up.
Okay, so it's quite a bit that I have actually on this.
So I know from this data and thank you, Melvang,
for such a extensive and detailed presentation.
The pandemic has been extremely challenging
on so many levels and it was anticipated,
I think that there would be a direct correlation
to the academic progress.
I can tell you that a teacher in the classroom
through the pandemic and through the years
that we've had in the past before we start,
before we encountered this new obstacle.
It has always been a steady progress
of students growth in the classroom.
And as the pandemic hit,
we were trying to survive in the class.
So I can say that that survive distance learning
and to have students be engaged.
And we were so focused on their social emotional status
and how they were feeling.
And that was also a hurdle that we encountered.
So with that being said,
I see the concern that the data shows
that students in California have not been progressing
at the rate that we would like to see.
However, also I heard Superintendent Thurmond
just announced yesterday morning
that the learning recovery block grant
will give students an opportunity to receive services
that will enhance classroom learning.
On a personal note, I want to share with you
that these funds are critical to school districts
and have, and they're extremely important to students
of low income students like mine.
Students will, districts will use funds
for learning recovery to have students receive
purposeful explicit intervention and reading.
As an elementary school teacher,
I have seen these funds help close the achievement gap.
I think that if we continue to provide students
with opportunities for tutoring,
expended after school and summer opportunities,
and teacher led professional learning in literacy,
science and math,
we will continue to see considerable improvements
in student performance and standards proficiency.
The data provided,
I think that some of the great tools that we have access to
is the California Assessment Accessibility Resource Graphics.
I think these graphics display universal tools
and designated supports and accommodations allowed
as part of the CASP and LPAC systems.
And there's also these great tools that I saw
from the Smarter Balanced Annotated Response Tool videos
and the Smarter Annotated Response Tool videos showcase
some of the student writing scores,
score on the Smarter Balanced ELA Performance Task
and how educators can use the tool
to support student writing.
I think these tools are useful when planning
and creating student goals.
As teachers, we collaborate and plan with our grade levels
during this allocated time.
And it's an opportunity to guide this work
by looking at student samples,
curating and developing lessons
that contribute standards proficiency.
As a teacher and a parent with children
taking the state test,
I think that it matters most in knowing where we're going
and how we're going to get there.
And now is a time to be deliberate
about the work we do in the class
and to collaborate with our peers.
When we work together,
we create a better learning experience
and teacher's collaboration
positively impacts student achievement
and allows us as educators to explore in your territory.
And all this data just tells me
that there's lots of work to be done.
And yesterday, a lot of it is not so much
at the rate that we're learning,
but how we pace ourselves.
And we are just so deliberate about the lessons
that we provide our students to increase student achievement.
And there's so much more,
but I wanna leave for public comment,
but I wanted to give you a little insight
as a teacher in the classroom when we see this data.
And we see that it's quick to say
that students aren't performing,
but I think that considering the situation,
I think we're progressing
and there's so much more work to be done.
And I think that teachers are ready to embark
on this journey to get our students to rise
to the occasion to increase our students' scores.
Thank you so much.
I wanna, as the second liaison,
offer a couple of comments about the work that Mal described.
First of all, I just wanna note my appreciation
for the improvements in the Spanish test
that really, that we asked for a couple of years ago.
It's great to see those coming to fruition.
They make it more authentic with speaking and writing
as well as listening and reading.
It's sort of beyond bubbling in.
It's really the use of the language
and real communication with open-ended responses,
which is something we're seeking to do in our assessments.
So it's great to see that coming to fruition.
Thank you, Mal and team
for all of the work that went into that.
And I really appreciate the deep dive
into the Smarter Balanced results.
As Gabriela said, we're all interested in understanding it
and then responding to the data.
The cohort level data are particularly interesting.
The cohort rate of gain that you showed,
which gives us some insight into how the investments
that we're making may be paying off.
Just another note for folks,
because we had the opportunity to look at the data
all kinds of different ways.
As I mentioned yesterday,
individual students are not falling backwards.
They are still continuing to make progress,
albeit in the years from 2020 to 2021 at a slower rate.
The overall levels of performance on the scale scores
are basically back to about where they were in 2015, 2016.
So we have been seeing increases each year.
This kind of resets us to that level,
but we also see this steeper potential gain.
And that's our goal in the coming years.
As member Roscoe Gonzalo said,
we have a great deal of work to do to accelerate learning
and that is going on.
What we know about how to accelerate learning,
Superintendent Thurman has a series of webinars
on learning acceleration.
CCEE has put in place a number of resources
for districts around learning acceleration.
Time matters, additional times that we've funded
after school and summer programming across the state.
Personalization matters, meeting students where they are
in their zone of proximal development around skills,
differentiating in the classroom,
but also adding tutoring, high intensity tutoring
and small group work in those additional areas of time,
both during the school day and beyond those
can dramatically improve performance.
We know that enthusiastic engagement
in thoughtful minds on hands on curriculum
that is focused on things that are relevant
and engaging for students makes a big difference.
We did put out digital guidance that identified
for math and ELA, the power standards, if you will,
and ways to engage students in critical learning
in each of the grades,
drawing on our common core standards,
but really with a fine tune
on how to integrate technology supports
around how to use power standards to dive deeply
in how to engage students critically.
And then the last thing that we know
really makes a difference is being in an environment,
a positive climate in which students are experiencing
a sense of safety and trust.
And we see in the search on social emotional learning
and restorative practices that when those elements are there,
student achievement goes up
because we use our brains more effectively
when we're in those kinds of environments.
So we're investing in all of those areas.
And I gave a little bit of the national perspective
from the NAEP tests yesterday,
and we have lost less ground than most states
and then the national average,
as I noted, we maintained in eighth grade
English language arts.
Another study just came out in the last couple of days,
I think it came out last Friday
and was reported on on Monday
from my colleagues, John Reardon at Stanford
who has a database of all of the districts in the country
and all of their progress and so on.
And he made the point about these learning
lags across the country and showed the relationship
between student poverty and gains.
And nationally, we see that districts
that serve wealthier, more affluent students
lost less ground generally than districts
that serve more low-income students.
And certainly we've seen the disparities
in access to resources in this state,
but we also have different outcomes than most states
in that we have large districts
that serve large numbers of low-income students,
students of color, like Los Angeles and San Diego
that I mentioned were high performers on the NAEP
and gained places like Oakland and Compton
and Salinas and others actually showed some stability
and gains during this period of time.
And I think that's because our funds went out
not only in quantity for these purposes, $24 billion,
but also with a very strong equity focus,
trying to be sure that the resources get to the students
and the districts that need them the most.
So we have a big job to do.
We are all focused on that job.
I think we should continue to study what's working,
what's not working and also redouble our efforts
and these data are critically important in that.
We can ask at this time any clarifying questions for Mal
about points of fact that she raised
and then we'll get public comment,
then we'll come back for further discussion.
Are there any clarifying questions?
Yes, member Petillo-Bronson.
So the item for action is actually,
I think all focused on the California Spanish assessment.
I also just wanted to confirm that this would be a moment
to discuss the redesign possibilities more broadly
that was sort of flagged, but it's not for action today.
Is that right?
Yes, we can discuss that.
We'll get to the discussion, absolutely.
And I'm glad to know that you have some ideas on that score.
So we'll look forward to that.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes, thank you.
And thank you Mal for the incredible presentation
this morning.
Wanted to find out like in lieu of the Spanish assessment
that's going to be developed,
students have been able to use IB scores, AP scores,
and other language classes, right?
So they still have access to the seal of biliteracy.
Okay, thank you.
And I guess the companion question might be
whether they would continue to have access
to multiple measures that they could use
to meet the expectations of the seal of biliteracy.
After this redesigned exam is available.
That may be something we need to take up in our discussion.
Member Patillo-Bronson.
Sorry, second question unrelated to the first.
The data that you described around more bright spots
around eighth grade ELA scores or ELA,
excuse me, as it pertains to the NAEP data.
I just wondered if Mal could comment on sort of
how to interpret what looks like a more promising trend
for eighth grade ELA along the NAEP dimension
versus the CASP.
And if that's something that is normally,
there's some sort of distance between how those two measures
sort of evaluate student progress.
Yeah, they're really two different sets of standards.
NAEP is our only national assessment
that every state participates in.
It's a sampling of students.
So the approach and the administration
is a little bit different.
I wasn't really, I didn't have any data handy right now
about comparing our results to NAEP right now,
but I don't know if our president wanted to say anything.
I was just concentrating
on our statewide assessments this morning.
What we just showed, what Mal just shared with us
did not break it down by grade level.
In the guide that Mal described,
there is a scale score trends by grade level.
And we can look at that.
I'll look at it before we come back for discussion,
but I believe that eighth graders also
did not lose as much of the loss or learning lag,
if you wanna use that term, was in the earlier grades.
And you see bigger learning lags
for the youngest students.
So we could compare eighth grade to eighth grade
if we look at different data,
which is not, it's all folded up together
on the data that Mal was just describing.
I see several people with clarifying questions.
Member Escobedo, then member Yoshimoto-Towry,
then member Olken.
And maybe Tony Alpert.
We do wanna get to public comment
before we have deep discussions.
So let's just be sure we keep these two clarifying questions.
Member Escobedo.
With the clarifying question and Nate versus our scores,
I was just wondering, I just found
as I compare standards from other states,
California standards typically are much more rigorous.
So that might be an explanation
of why there might be just a difference.
Yeah, that is true.
We have both more rigorous standards and higher cut scores
for our proficiency levels.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Thank you.
I understand now why we call these mega items.
So I'm gonna limit my clarifying questions
just to the Spanish, the item for up for action today.
But I do have three very quick ones.
The first one, Mal, is do we have an extent
of the field test for 23, 24?
Yeah, like when it'll take place and who's included?
I saw in the literature that there's about 300 students,
ideally, for each grade level.
Are you talking about the NAEP?
No, the Spanish language.
Oh, in terms, no, I don't have that handy.
Let me get that in terms of the field testing.
Yes, I don't have that handy.
I will get that from my staff.
That's okay as a follow-up, thank you.
And then the second question is do we,
will there be sample questions written
for the Spanish language assessment like we have eventually?
We do already have the practice and training tests.
So that's available publicly.
But in terms of the expanded, like the speaking
and the expanded writing expansion,
I'm sure that we will always provide
as part of the development process,
sample items out there for the field to refer to.
Thank you.
And then my last, again, brief clarifying question is,
in the speaking section when the student's speaking
is recorded, is it using headphones or is it one-on-one?
How is that, what's that process being explored?
Well, now the only assessment we have
that assesses speaking is in the LPAC, right?
The English Language Proficiency Test.
And in that, I believe it is recorded,
what's in person, the teacher listens and then scores,
but it's also recorded as well.
So just for read-behind purposes,
but we have those capabilities.
So we're thinking about the speaking portion of the CSA
to be similar to how we do the LPAC?
No, at this point, it's not defined yet.
I was just referring to a similar test
that we have that would have speaking,
but those would probably be options.
But in terms of the specifics for administration,
those specific directions will still be in the works.
So if I speak prematurely,
those are probably various options,
but it will be more defined in the future.
Thank you, thank you.
And before I go to member Olken,
I think Tony Alpert had raised his hand
because he wanted to respond
to one of the clarifying questions earlier.
Is that right, Tony?
Yes, thank you.
For the record, Tony Alpert,
Executive Director for Smarter Balanced.
In addition to the factual representation
that California standards are more rigorous
than other states,
the Smarter Balanced Assessment is a ELA literacy test,
which includes, as you're aware,
listening and research and writing.
NAEP is a reading test.
So in part, what we need to do
is dig in a little bit deeper
on some of these other dimensions of ELA,
especially writing.
So I suspect that,
whereas reading probably was more sustained
during the pandemic,
writing probably fell a little bit astray,
and that might be why we're seeing differential results
between NAEP and Smarter Balanced.
Thank you.
Member Olken.
Thank you for all the analysis
and both here and in the interpretation guide.
It's very helpful and I really appreciate it.
My clarifying question is just,
I noticed in the slides and in my,
jeez, sorry,
and in my quick perusal of the interpretation guide,
I don't see a similar analysis.
So we have the ELA and math percentage of students
met or exceeded standards by grade level
and then by subgroups.
Is there an analysis that is at the lowest level?
So it's like from 2019 to 2022,
the percentage of students who are at far below
so that we can see how that's changed over time.
Because when I'm thinking about the acceleration,
learning acceleration,
that's a group that feels really important to be addressing.
So I'm just wondering if that analysis has been done
and if not, if it can be for us.
I will address that,
that all those specific results are available
in the public reporting side.
So by each of the achievement levels is already there.
We were just taking some of the high level
or key points of the results to share with you.
But if you go to the link that I provided
in the interpretation guide is also there as well.
When you are on the public reporting side,
you could get all the details,
like how many students are tested at each level,
how many students are at each performance level,
across the grades, across the various groupings.
Okay, and it's rolled up in a similar way
to make it easy to see just like this.
That's right.
Fantastic, thank you.
Yeah, you're welcome.
It looks like Tony, do you have your hand up again?
Or is that from before?
I do, thank you.
And I really appreciate California's transparency
around public reporting.
I think it's also really important to look at the students
at the lowest level of performance by group,
demographics and program participation
because the strategies that districts will need to use
will be different regarding their needs
to accelerate those all students learning.
Absolutely.
The other thing I would just say is we're dealing,
digging into the needs in the field
is that you get a broad sense from scores
like the end of the year test in Smarter Balanced,
but there are also interim assessment tools
that are part of Smarter Balanced
and other diagnostic tools that districts are using.
Those are really what get activated
at the beginning of the school year
when you're trying to figure out
exactly what a student needs and knows and needs
in the next coming months.
Seeing no other clarifying questions,
I think we should move to public comment
and let's see if we have any public comment.
Yes, there are currently six callers in the queue.
I will open up the phone line now.
Good morning, State Board of Education.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Caller ending in the last four digits, 8256.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Okay, moving on.
Caller with the last four digits, 5116.
Please start your public comment now.
Good morning, Jessica Sacco on behalf of Children Now.
I wanna thank the department for sharing their plans
for the upcoming year in regards to how they plan
to revise the student score reports
to better communicate with families.
We really think it's critically important
to help families understand how well their student is doing
and inclusion of information such as recent progress
can be a critical step in helping families
support the student meet the state standards
and eventually graduate college and career ready.
One of the important pieces of information
that was left out of the student score reports
are the claim scores that are no longer available
due to the abbreviated blueprint.
Those claim scores include information in language art
such as separate scores for reading, writing, listening,
and research and inquiry.
That detailed information at the student level
is really helpful for students and families
so that they can target the support that their child needs.
Currently, they are only available at the group level,
which is not very useful for families.
We would also encourage the use of comparison data points,
visuals on your progress,
as well as additional information
to help families understand Lexile and Quantile scores
and how they may access resources
to support students consistent with their level.
And we look forward to helping the department
engage with parents and families and communities
in order to inform the development
of the next iteration of student score reports.
Thank you, Callie, your time is up.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Good morning, Liz Guillen with Public Advocates
for the LCFF Coalition.
Yes, appreciate the data that's presented on test scores
and also appreciate the positive words about the results.
So the community and various student groups that are lagging
that were lagging even before the pandemic,
these results are catastrophic.
And it's not even clear whether or not our students
will have the time to catch up.
For me, it highlights what we have been asking for
both at the legislature and through the department.
For greater transparency in the use of these funds.
The first report on the use of the learning recovery block
grant is December, 2024.
And we urge and beg the department to require
more transparency about who's being consulted
on the use of these funds.
Thank you, thank you, your time is up.
In addition to it.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Hi, this is Doug McRae,
a retired testing specialist from Monterey.
I'm going to do quickly two things, item six and item 12
since I was not successful with six.
For item six on the consent yesterday,
I submitted to your electronic folder
a concern over overpayments to DTS
in the 2020 and 2020 budget.
I'm going to do quickly two things,
a concern over overpayments to DTS
in the 2020 and 2021 testing cycles,
receiving a fully budgeted amount
rather than a cost reimbursement amount.
I estimated the overpayments to be $123 million.
There will be several ways for ETS
to return those dollars to California.
For item number 12,
I submitted to your electronic folder,
a preliminary version of four-page
smarter balance concessions
concessions concessions wide
gains Gordai data document
with results from 10 of 11 states.
Bottom line is that the gains from 2021 to 2022
were very positive,
justifying claims by state leaders.
They were headed in the right direction.
Be happy to provide additional information
for both item six and 12.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, this is Manuel Vendroso,
Associate Director of Policy
of California's Together.
We first want to thank the board
and CDU for reviewing
how assessment results are reported
to students and families
and appreciate the plan
to make the future understanding more accessible.
For the report for the
English language proficiency assessment,
we recommend that these clearly display
whether a student is making adequate progress
over time towards English proficiency
and whether a student is at risk
what has become a long-coming disarmament.
Further, the current report
on the alternative ALPAC assessment
lacks the clarity provided
in the standard ALPAC report,
and we recommend making it easier to understand.
Lastly, we are grateful for the board and CDU
as we continue to implement
the California Spanish assessment,
and thank them for continuing to engage our coalition
and we can put in discussions.
The CFA is a key aspect of California's efforts
to expand students' languages
and we're hoping we'll listen.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, Peter Ahern,
California Association of Science Educators
speaking on behalf of the
Coalition of Science Educators
and organizations who submitted a letter
to explain our thoughts in detail.
We have been working together to advance
equity in science education throughout California
and shared our blueprint in the letter.
We are grateful to CDE for the work
in building the science tools for teachers
and working with teachers in building this resource.
We look forward to helping CDE to expand and promote.
We also would like to thank CDE
for its hard work in getting science data
linked to this year's dashboard.
The scores indicate that districts
have still not invested in science
and in GSS implementation.
They are not likely to do so
until science is included on the main dashboard.
We are grateful for the support that
the State Board of Education has given
to including science as a dashboard indicator
once two consecutive years of data are available
and look forward to science being on the next week.
Having a strong science education for all students
is vital to provide full access
to STEM career pathways.
It is also critical that California has a
science literate workforce and citizenry.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi. Good morning.
My name is Dr. Rosario Moreno.
I'm the Director of Parent Relations
for California Association of Bilingual Education,
School Administrator and University Professor.
Share with you that in Alameda County,
only one school district out of 18
had to include a goal for English learners in the LCAP.
Keep in mind that the county enrolls
43,020 English learners in only one district
or 5% of the districts needs to address
the growth of English language proficiency
for the students.
The accountability system only identifies
two districts or 10% out of 18
are eligible for additional support
to differentiated assistance.
The issue of transparency,
addressing principle 6 speaks to the need
to shed light on language and academic needs
of English learners.
I think we would all agree that in the number
of English learners in Alameda County,
the accountability system
Excuse me.
I apologize. I think you want to be calling back
for the following item.
This is requiring our statewide assessment
results. I think you want to call in for the next item.
Okay. Thank you.
That concludes public comment
for item number 12.
Alright. Thank you very much.
We're now open for board discussion
on this item.
And I know that member Yoshimoto
Tari, you had an additional
area of inquiry
that you were holding
for discussion.
Vice President Glover Woods,
you ready to jump in?
Yes, I sure can.
First, again, thank you so much, Mal,
for always giving such a wonderful
presentation and outlining all of the things
regarding assessment and quite
excited to see the development
for the California Spanish assessment.
I just wanted to
underscore a couple of
pieces and also make a
request. As was
stated, the data
that we were looking at with the SBAT
should be for
2022 considered baseline
and I agree. I think it's important
to look back at what has
occurred and how the
pandemic has impacted instruction.
I also believe that we are now
in 2022, in the
2022-23 school year, and we need
to look at the data
where it is and make some
actionable
steps forward to make
some adjustments. And saying so,
I am concerned about
the scores that we are
looking at and that have been shown
for our African American student
group as well as our English
learner student group.
So I encourage both at the state level
and also at the local LEA level that we
do some further desegregation
of those student groups
to see
other information that might be
illuminated in the data once
we look at
those student groups in a bit more
of a fine-tune, if you
will. Also, just
want to highlight President
Darling-Hammond really outlined
some very key
accelerating learning strategies
and actions that we need to
keep in mind as we look at
the utilization of the funds that
have been put forward. And
just really, again, looking forward
from where we are now to what needs
to happen. Because the data
really shows that
those gaps that were present before
the pandemic for multiple student
groups still do exist.
And I just strongly
encourage all of us, those in
the field as well as those of us on the board,
to look at what are those strategies
we need to use to
close those gaps and bring our other
student groups forward. Thank you.
Thank you.
Member Petillo-Bronson,
Member Rodriguez.
Good morning and thank
you, Mao, again, for the presentation
which was very, very helpful
and as always
brings to light lots of
important trend lines.
So I guess
the first set of comments really is just around
what our vice
chair was just describing of wanting
to keep an
eye on both where
the pandemic exacerbated versus
created new gaps
that didn't exist before.
And this is not
something that I necessarily expect
today's presentation
to solve, but I do think
I'm trying to think about
what is the role of the state board
in both being able
to disaggregate
not just data, but which
intervention strategies
are most impactful
in actually
reaching different student groups
and different disparities numbers.
So I'm
delighted and relieved
to see some acceleration
of learning patterns and catch-up
and also expecting
that there'll be some
differential progress as between
if it's tutoring or after school or summer
that shows
progress for different student groups.
And I'm not sure if
the CASC data can get us
there, but I'm putting it on
sort of our list of things
to think about for the future
for
making sure that we're
lifting all boats, but also recognizing
that different
boats have different levels of buoyancy
coming into it.
So the
second thing that I wanted to raise
up was the
issue of redesign and
the calendar that you shared moving
forward. I'm sort of picking
up on the prior conversation
that we had
at the last board or maybe
two board meetings ago around
whether and how
to create space
for school
averages, district averages,
and statewide averages
to be included for
information that's available to parents
on the score reports.
I think we had
you had shared in the last meeting that there's
sort of a time delay between the time
available for
individual scores to go
home to families versus
when the
averages would be made available.
So I wanted to first ask if there's any
update about being able to align
those
to be able to actually
provide those averages to parents
and if
there is a technical challenge
that makes
the creation of those district-wide
and state and school-wide averages
challenging if
we can include prior
year averages.
I could
say a little bit about that.
Please do, yes.
With
it is always our intent
to include them.
It's just that at this point the data
is not available due to
the suspension in prior
years, right, 2020-21.
So we
didn't have enough
data to report and that is why we
were excluding them from the current
year one, but through the process of
redesign this year, we can
certainly continue to look at
that and as
we progress and more years of data
are available, we can
put
as much information as
reasonable on
the student score
reports, including this, or with
a lot of technology advancement
then we could
probably find better ways of getting data
to students and parents in even
more timely, in a more timely
manner and provide more data
and information as well. So we
look forward to your feedback and we have
this as on our bucket list of
continuing to do
and pursue, so I appreciate
you bringing it up.
Thank you.
Member Rodriguez and then
member Yoshimoto-Tari.
Thank you.
So first
of all, I'd like to thank our liaisons.
Member Orozco
and President Darlene
Hammond on your
the way you
framed
first of all, shout
out to teacher-led
practices.
Thank you so much for that because
that's important, right, for us to have
we know our students
and
and for us to help each other
help our students
grow is so important
and also
President
Darlene Hammond, you mentioned
a lot of the
funds that, you know, are going
into, that we've
committed to support
our students and
the social-emotional
learning. One of
my concerns is also the concern
that Vice President
Glover Woods raised,
you know, are the students who
just, they seem to be continuing
to fall
behind. And
my experience as a teacher for
25 years has
it seems like there's
a sociocultural
component,
you know, where
I feel like
students have
been disengaged. You were mentioning
engagement, right? They've been disengaged from the
process and
you know, we really
wanted to challenge them. We want to
have them be in robust
classes and give them
the props so that they can be
successful. But the first
part is the engagement, right?
How do we make them
active participants in the
learning process in constructing
their learning? And so
that's a question that
has come up for me
many times and especially
looking at this data.
You know, I want
to see our students continue to grow.
And
so there's
the
commitment that we have made as a
state makes me
hopeful because
we have to, and then
we have to ensure that it's being
that the students who really need those
supports, whether it's pull-out
interventions, the tutoring,
right, if it's done well,
and students
have a chance to have feedback
with a person
who's supporting them.
Pulling
students out, identifying students
that need that extra support is
essential. And I also
want to
comment on the seal
of biliteracy and
just what an impact that's had,
speaking of engagement, on a lot
of the students in my community
because
their language is being valued,
right? You know, they feel like, yes, we
are bilingual
and students who maybe aren't
bilingual yet, we're working towards that.
And so
that is
a wonderful tool
for
encouragement and engagement
that we provide as a state.
And
lastly, I want to comment also
on, you know, the
science and the importance of science.
On Halloween,
I started my class for the
first few minutes going over the history
of vampires
and,
you know, and just how
there were vampires in Mesopotamia
and Greece, in Mexico,
and oftentimes, you know, right, like in
ancient civilizations,
they were used to explain phenomena,
natural phenomena.
But then, you know, when
the vampire became big in
I believe it was Romania, Bulgaria,
it was
to explain a pandemic. People were dying.
But they didn't know
about the science of death, right?
And so
I was telling my students and I,
we were talking about the importance of science
because as we learn
more, we don't rely on
supernatural theories to explain
natural phenomena.
And they
were really excited.
They were like, science!
And so anyway, yes, science
is so important.
You know, especially in this
era of disinformation,
when we go to the science,
we can, when we have that scientific
training, we're able to explain a lot more.
So thank you.
Thanks so much.
Member Yoshimoto
Tauri.
Thank you, Board President.
I have some general comments on the information
items and then a
comment or just for discussion on the
action item. So first,
our Board President and Vice President
did an excellent job in setting the stage
around the context for the
assessment. So I don't want to reiterate any
of that, but I did want to add that
I think that
we learned a lot in the
during the pandemic or now the
endemic about how to
use multi-tiered systems
of support to really be
pronounced and explicit
about those, not only
in academics, but in
very human needs like mental
and physical well-being,
food sustenance, housing
support, as
well as remembering
well-being, joy and connectedness
and the importance of that.
And never before in my
30 years did I see
not only educators, but
maintenance and operation workers,
librarians, principals, city staff,
municipalities,
frontline health care
workers supporting one another
and being surrounded by private
philanthropy and community-based
organizations. So I hope that we
take that with us in our recovery
phase and use that to our benefit
in the acceleration phase that
our educators
want and need that support
like we talked about yesterday in the
community school effort
and wanted to
bring the community school effort into the context
today as we think about our
recovery and our acceleration.
In terms of science,
I believe science is the place
where reading comprehension gets applied,
mathematics gets applied,
and true critical thinking
and inquiry processes get applied.
So I just want to commend the department
for working on the Tools for Teachers
and those 70 mini lessons.
I think those are really important and I just
wish that we can continue that work
into next year.
And then in terms of the last
information item I wanted to address,
again, gratitude to the CD staff
for working with the SBA Consortium,
etc.
And I just want to reiterate the
importance of having the claim scores even
though we're using the modified, more concise
smarter balance assessment
and to reiterate Board Member Portillo
Bronson's comments about the comparative
data for parents and families.
I think that
our students will benefit from our families,
our educators, our counselors
understanding what specific
areas of support and instruction are
needed. And
the work on the focus IABs
have been incredible, but I would ask
in next year's work plan that we include
the shorter
possibilities for a shorter
ICA as well
that matches the shorter summative
because many schools want to
use the ICA
as a formative assessment
and then have multiple forms of that
ICA so they can do like a beginning
and possibly a middle
before the summative to give
our educators
an opportunity to see growth over time.
And then finally
for our Spanish language assessment,
Mal, I was just hoping in
a moment you could explain
to us the process
the department used to determine the
descriptors,
and then also
given that we're so early in the process
of the CSA development, the Spanish
language assessment development, there's
an opportunity to revisit and revise
the descriptors even if we
approve those today.
And I'm asking primarily because
I noticed that the one
of the terms used is limited
to a limited degree.
And the
first time, it just
reminds me of the term limited English
proficiency that we've tried so hard to move away
from. And when limited
English proficiency was first used, it was
first used in 1975 associated
with Lau
versus Nichols.
And we've moved, we've moved, you know,
we've grown a lot in the last four years
in regard to our belief around
assets-based language.
Our
students learning English and in this case
our students learning Spanish
bring other languages and other
assets to the table.
And so I
just wondered about the process
used to formulate the descriptors
and if there's any room to possibly
revisit those
again, even if
approved today for
the immediate work plan.
Thank you.
So
lots of issues there.
Tony raised his hand because I think he
wants to answer one of your questions.
And then Mao, if we can come to you
for that last question.
Tony.
Thank you. For the record, Tony Alpert, Executive
Director, Smarter Balanced.
The
reason why we can support a more
concise blueprint on the
summative test is because it's adaptive.
If we look
and similarly
the blocks that we have
in the interim assessment are focused
on a smaller body of content.
And so to
include the ICA,
which mimics the blueprint
of the summative assessment
and
in a shortened manner,
it would be a short fixed
form, which would work for
about this portion of the student
population. And so
for most students, it would not
be reliable. And certainly the
claim information
would be insufficient
under any conditions
to report on that
broad swat of content.
So what
we recommend is that
if folks want to use
the items
from the ICA, they can use the interim
assessment item portal
to create their own version
of an assessment
and using the items from
Smarter Balanced. And that's
available in Tools for Teachers. So
they could link together
multiple IABs
and use that information
as part of their
formative assessment process.
Thank
you.
We're going to come back in, I think,
January to talk also about the
demonstration
of content that the Smarter Balanced
team has done
with bringing performance tasks
into the
school year. And some
states are
sort of piloting that with the idea
of using that also to develop
claim scores that could be available
for all students. So there's a lot of
things to talk about there.
Marianne, did you want
to answer one of the questions? Is that why
you're popping up, Marianne Arcila,
our ETS representative?
Yes. For the record,
hello, everyone.
Good morning, board members. My name is Marianne
Arcila, executive director at ETS.
We serve
as a state testing contractor.
I wanted to respond
about the process
for the
descriptors.
And so
the CSA has
been around for a few years
now, and at the very beginning
there was a multi-step
process to develop
the descriptors.
And for each process, for
each state,
we
had teachers, we had educators
come together
to identify,
to go through the standards, identify
what
a
student
at each level
should be able
to do or would know
what they would know how to do.
And then they helped
draft the descriptors.
And so we did that
with educators at each stage
and at each point
we
provided them to the CDE. CDE
provided the recommendations.
There were revisions
when they were received by the CDE
and the CDE provided
the recommended descriptors to the
state board for approval.
With the addition
of speaking
and writing
or for CSA, for this
expansion, we did something very
similar.
And then, and so that's
the recommendations, the revised
descriptors are what you're seeing now.
We ran them
through a number of reviews
externally
and then with the CDE and the CDE
made the final recommendations
that you're seeing today.
Hope that answers your question.
I think that answers one part of the question.
The other part was whether we can rethink
the use of the term limited.
For President, I
could probably address that a little bit.
And in addition to what Marianne said,
we did vet these
by our experts, as
I mentioned when we worked on
and educators as Marianne mentioned
when they
were first developed. So
we can change the word at this time
to something different like we did for
LPAC. For example,
we had beginning at that time
and then we changed it to
beginning instead of limited.
So we are aware that that would probably
be a phrase we wouldn't want to use going
forward. So thank you for bringing that
up. And we are taking note
of that. And during
this process, we can certainly
do that.
Thanks so much. I
have a question on the Spanish assessment too.
Member Olken, are you
on that same point or a different point?
Okay, you go first.
Thank you.
So I was hoping to
return to the question that got
briefly
raised during our
clarifying questions about
the seal of biliteracy.
Once the
that
get my CSA
is
becomes
a valid means
to
assess
seal of biliteracy, there's a question
whether the ways that students
currently are able to demonstrate
their biliteracy will still be
available so that we have multiple
measures. And I just wondered if
that's something we thought
if that's something that's being considered
so that we
could and if not
maybe we could we.
Now, do you know the answer
to that question?
That's really a policy
use question.
I don't have an answer.
I'm sorry. I couldn't catch all of it because someone told
me I was echoing.
My technology here.
Yeah, and it sounds like
perhaps maybe the
it's more of a
question to put out there
more broadly than to you in particular.
It may be a question for us.
I think, you know, I would
It's a question for us.
I think I hear you
affirming the value of having
multiple ways of doing
that. I believe that that is
still going to be the case, but I'd love
to be sure that that's the case so that
students don't have to take
more tests than are needed
to be able to demonstrate their
competence. If they're taking AP
Spanish, you know, and then that's
one of the ways, you know, in then
we should preserve that option as long
as and other options
that have been on the table.
That's exactly what I was trying to say. Thank you.
Vice President Glover Woods nodding.
So I think I'm getting some
sense of a sense. So I think we want to check into
the fact, check into what the
policy framework is for that and
weigh in if there is any question about
that.
I have just one last question about the blueprint.
When I raised
the notion about speaking,
Mal, you said that that was not on
the table, but I thought
in the original slides I saw that
right around slide eight or nine
that
it did say that speaking
was one of the domains along
with could you go back to the
in the slides unless they changed from the earlier
slides I had seen previous
to the meeting.
Yes, speaking
is hard.
Yes, I just couldn't get
there fast enough.
I'm in this room and there's a lot other noise.
I don't know if you guys are getting some
feedback. We are. We are getting
your feedback. It's
lovely to hear your voice twice.
Which is what we're hearing.
So yeah, just to clarify
that the proposed
revised TSA general
ALDs will add speaking
to the general ALDs.
They will
include domains for
speaking as well
as writing and
reading.
I'm not sure if listening is there, but
that is something we
talked about earlier as well.
The overall scale score with three achievement
levels and reading, writing, listening and speaking
domains was on
slide 10.
I'm happy about that.
And
that is the kind of
blueprint we want to approve, I think.
So at this point, I think we've
made all of our comments.
Take a motion if there is
one to
respond to the CDE recommendations
and there they are again.
May I get a motion?
So moved.
All right. Thank you.
And second.
Thank you very much.
Brooks, can you call the roll call vote?
Apologies.
We didn't catch who was the second.
Member
Orozco-Gonzalez.
Thank you.
All right.
President Darling-Hammond.
Aye.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Aye.
Member Olken.
Yes.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Yes.
Member Porter.
Motion carries unanimously.
Terrific.
We are one minute ahead of schedule.
So we will now take a 16 minute break
and I will see you back at 10.45.
Remember to
stay in the meeting but turn off your
video and your microphone.
All right.
Welcome back.
Let's ask Brooks to call the roll to
reestablish the quorum.
Welcome back.
Member Escobedo.
Yes.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
I see Vice President Glover-Woods.
So.
Member Lewis.
Yes.
Member McQuillan.
Member Olken.
Yes.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Vice President Glover.
Yes.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Yes.
Everyone is present.
All right.
The next exciting item
is item 13.
The update on the implementation of the
integrated local state and federal
accountability and continuous improvement
system. Approval of the California
school dashboard principles.
Review of the local control and
accountability plan requirements for
the English learner student group.
And dashboard outreach activities.
And the item for action
is the CDE recommends the approval
of the California school dashboard
principles.
This item will be presented by Cindy
Kazanis and Josh Strong of the CDE.
As well as Eric Crane
from West Ed and representatives of
the Sacramento County Office of
Education.
I saw Shanna Cook Harvey over there.
So hello, Shanna.
And others from the Sacramento County.
Cindy, please begin.
Thank you, President
Darling-Hammond. I'm Cindy Kazanis.
I'm the director of the analysis
measurement and accountability reporting
division. It's great to be with you this
morning on a Thursday.
We have been extremely
busy these last couple of weeks,
if not this whole year.
We're going to hear some of the culmination
of the work for
accountability today
for the year.
And we'll give you a little bit of a
glimpse into the public
release that we're planning for in December.
Before I get started, I just want
to acknowledge yesterday you had a celebration
for two of my favorite attorneys
in the entire state. Amy Holloway
and Judy Sias.
And I, just from a personal
perspective, what great examples
of career public servants
they are and have learned
so much from them. And their leadership
has been invaluable to our work,
not only in accountability, but
in compliance and other
things that are maybe not so exciting
to the public, but are necessary
pieces of our democracy.
And so I just wanted to acknowledge
you have two amazing
individuals
who have been supporting your work for a
number of years. And it's
going to be a lot of big shoes to fill.
So shifting over to today's topics,
we're going to talk about our dashboard principles,
the California School Dashboard Principles
through Attachment 1.
You're going to learn a little bit more
with my colleague Josh Strong
about our English Learner Student Group and
their role in the local control and accountability
plan process. And then
we'll close it out with our dashboard
outreach activities.
We are all over the state. I just
came back from Anaheim and going to San
Diego tonight, and I'm really excited to share
with you how these activities
are really, I think, impacting
the field in a positive manner.
As already stated by President Darlene Hammond,
the item recommendation is
the California Department of Education,
CDE, recommends approval
of the California School Dashboard Principles.
So shifting over to
Attachment 1,
one thing I've been reflecting on, because
we keep getting a lot of correspondence, I think,
that is confused about the
purpose of these principles. So I
looked back at one of the organizations
that are, that we follow as a
state agency, which is the Council of
Chief State School Officers.
And back in 2019, they put out
a really good handbook for state
agencies to look at in thinking about
managing changes that affect
accountability outcomes.
And one of the statements in that
document really, I think,
really summarizes today's work
around the principles. And I'm going to just
quote it verbatim so I don't
mess this up, but it talks about
many of the changes to the accountability
and assessment systems are necessary.
And, if implemented with fidelity,
can effectively support
the ultimate goal of any
educational system, improving
learning for all students.
However, implementing these changes
can be complicated, multi-layered,
and multi-faceted endeavor involving
many actors and stakeholders.
A change to one component or aspect of
either accountability or assessment systems
can lead to a chain reaction
that affects other components or other
aspects in both systems.
Changes generally have implications
and consequences, intended
or unintended, on the interpretation
and use of accountability outcomes.
States, therefore, need to
thoughtfully plan
and carefully manage the changes
with respect to implementation,
reporting, and communication.
So before you today is
the start of that process.
We know there are changes coming to this dashboard.
You've heard it in the last item
around science. You've heard it
in prior board meetings around English
learners and
the use of the English learner progress indicator
and the academic
indicator. And so the principles
are intended to have
the board really
document the work that has been done to
date, but also to look forward
to using these as a
basis to support decisions.
It doesn't mean that these principles can't
change, but in fact this allows
us to at least have a framework
and some guardrails for moving forward.
We are committed as a department to
bringing these principles back to you
annually. If there are adjustments that need to be
made to allow
for additional indicators to come in
in a different fashion than what was first
envisioned, I absolutely
will bring that to you. So I just want to make
sure that I put that lens forward
as this is simply the beginning of
a conversation we know is going to be a long
one over the next couple of years.
So when
we looked and we heard from you
and from others in
anticipation of the adoption
of these principles at
this meeting, we incorporated
changes that we
again heard at the State Board of Education meeting,
the CPAC meeting, and members of the public.
And so in table one
I want to make sure that you have that in front of you
because we're not going to show you that table. We're going to show you
the clean version of the principles.
That
table one shows you
the September version, it shows you
the November version, and then we were able to
use track changes
to show you what had been changed in
response to your feedback.
We heard that there's some grammatical
pieces that may need to be changed
and so we look forward to your feedback
around
consistent use of the word dashboard
principles as opposed to accountability
system.
And so to get us started,
let me just reiterate the purpose of the dashboard.
The California School
Dashboard provides parents and educators
with meaningful information
on school and district progress
so they can participate in decisions to improve
student learning. And with that,
I am pleased to turn this over
to my colleague from West
Ed, or rather the R15
Comprehensive Center, Eric Crane.
Thank you, Director Kazanis.
President Darling-Hammond, Vice President
Glover-Woods, Chief Deputy
Superintendent Nicely,
and distinguished board members, good morning.
I'm Eric Crane
and I'm a senior researcher and technical
assistance provider with the Region 15
Comprehensive Center at West Ed.
I want to start with a little bit of background
about the comp centers.
We provide high quality, intensive
capacity building services
to states in the western region that includes
California as well as Nevada,
Utah, and Arizona.
Our focus is in helping
state agencies
implement evidence-based
programs and practices and interventions
that support improved outcomes for
students and educators.
The context for the principles
was that there
includes that there were some changes
at the CDE, at the leadership level,
new board members,
and the importance
of identifying,
documenting, enshrining,
and memorializing formally
some of the discussions of
past boards as relates to the accountability
system, specifically
focusing on the dashboard.
So the department reached out to Region
15 to facilitate
the discussion and to document
these principles.
The request stems
in some measure from
a successful
work that was done in a different
context where when CDE
with the SBE was looking
at the development of a growth model,
the establishment documentation
of principles around the
growth model was helpful to that
process. So the request was that
the comp center provide
content expertise, facilitate
conversation about the principles among CDE
leadership, and present to groups
such as the TDG and
CPAG, take the lead
in documenting the discussion, and
then present to the board.
So I want
to start, and let me acknowledge the
rich robust discussion back at the
September meeting. You'll find
that while there are not
many changes from September,
those that have been made in the interim
do reflect that discussion
and they're pretty
significant in their scope
and framing about some of the issues
here. So Dashboard Principle 1
is that the dashboard focuses on
elements that express the commitment
to a well-rounded, well-supported
education and makes space for what is
valued locally. The change
here was just really one of clarification.
The past version had the word
priorities in there and
there was consensus that for clarity
and to minimize any chance of
confusion with
LCFF priorities that
the word commitment gets
substituted in for
priorities.
Dashboard Principle
2, that the dashboard reports opportunity
and performance gaps among student
groups through the equity report that
is available for each state indicator.
So this principle
received the most robust discussion
at the September meeting
and has the most significant
changes, both in the
main text and in the supporting
paragraph.
The changes here
elevate
the
idea of
and the importance of highlighting
opportunity and performance gaps.
That was something that we heard loud and
clear from the board back in September
and so that language of
opportunity and performance gaps
is in the statement proper
as well as the
elaboration within the supporting
paragraph. So
it's Principle 2 that saw the biggest
changes since September.
Principle 3
that the dashboard reports each
indicator separately. Now the thing to
be said about Principle 3
is that this one
also saw pretty significant
edits since September.
The framing
back in September was
gives equal
weight to each indicator and
those six words
contain a
lot and really upon
reflection really needed to be
expanded into two.
So the old
dashboard Principle 3
from the September meeting has now become
Principles 3 and 4.
And in this
treatment with Principle 3
we're highlighting that the
different indicators are reported
separately.
The big idea here in
the revised Principle 3
is that California
in significant
contrast to
most of the states
does not apply X percent
to this indicator and Y percent to this
other indicator to boil it down
to a single index.
By highlighting each
indicator separately
California's made a thoughtful
decision that
discussions about each
indicator are important
on their own and that the color
based system that California uses
facilitates those kinds of conversations
about how a school or
LEA is doing on
say graduation rate or
say mathematics performance.
So Principle 3 is about
keeping the reporting separate
for each indicator.
The new Principle 4
is the other part that was
in the former Principle 3
and that's that the dashboard values each indicator
equally. By not
putting a percentage weight
on each indicator and by showing
each indicator standing on
its own the dashboard
draws just as much attention
to each and every indicator
and in fact
in the early versions of many
state systems
test scores predominated in
their importance in the system
not so with California's system.
Yes the number of indicators
do
lean toward academic
performance and academic indicators and that's
in keeping with the
requirements of ESSA and
with California's priorities.
But again there's no
naming or over weighting
of one indicator over another.
Taken in the aggregate there
is a substantial focus
on academic indicators.
Principle 5 the dashboard
values high performance and growth
equally. No changes
here.
Principle 6
the dashboard
reports transparently and
comprehensively at the state district school
and student group levels.
Again from September no
changes here.
Principle 7
the dashboard promotes
effective visualization, clear communication
and thorough documentation.
For here just the supporting
paragraph had just a small technical
cleanup.
Dashboard
principle 8 that the dashboard
reflects technical quality through
measures that are valid and reliable.
Principle 9
that the dashboard leverages
the expertise and the perspectives
of a broad set of educational
partners and community members.
Again no changes
since September.
Principle 10
the dashboard promotes coherence between
data reporting and support
improvement programs.
Again no changes. And finally
dashboard
principle 11 the dashboard is
subject to continuous revision and
improvement. And I'll just say something
about again this was no changes since
September but I'll say something about this and I think
Director Kazan has framed it really nicely
in the opening that
the process of
looking at the dashboards
it's the department's intent to bring
these annually before the board and
that would be my recommendation as well
is that in pulling together
principles
things do change
and the idea of
looking at the principles
annually makes a lot of
good sense and so it was
really helpful to hear that framing and
I think that's something to be supported.
Really with
that that's the gist
of the changes in terms of the dashboard
principles and I'll pass it back
over to Director Kazanis.
Thank you Eric. President Darling-Hammond
did you want to pause for
clarifying questions or how would you like to proceed?
I was just thinking that
same thing I think we should
this is a as everyone knows the
mega accountability item and so
we will try to pause
by topic area. Are there
any clarifying questions at this moment?
That was perfectly clear.
Continue on.
Thank you.
Okay we're going to shift
over to attachment two and as
I mentioned we have a whole team
supporting this attachment.
I'm going to provide you a bit of a
brief background as to
how we came to this topic
and then I will turn it over to my colleague
Josh Strong from
the local
agency
system of support
office. Lasso. I know the
acronym well. The words
in between I've forgotten
this morning. Thank you for
the assist.
Alright so just briefly
to review your discussion
from September from just
a little over
six seven weeks ago.
The department in response
to inquiries
from the state board of education we provided
a comprehensive review
of first state board of education
prior action on
defining the English owner student
group for the dashboard academic
indicators as allowed
under the Every Student Succeeds Act.
We also provided
historical information on
SBE prior action on the development
of the English learner progress indicator.
You heard a presentation
from Kenji Hakuta
who's a national expert on
English learner students. I heard his name this
morning in Mal's presentation
on assessment so Kenji
still seems to be working even though he's
retired and
specifically Dr.
Hakuta's work on the structure of the English
learner student group as it was
intended under the Every Student Succeeds
Act back from
2014 and
2015.
So just as a
reminder the definition for California
of English learners in the
academic indicators are
students who are reported as an English
learner student any time during
the academic year including
in September the purpose
for including RFIPs
in the academic indicator
for our English learner student
group is first that it removes
disincentives for
reclassifying
students.
The purpose for including
RFIPs in the
academic indicator
for our English learner student
group is first that it
removes disincentives
for reclassification the districts
once experienced under that old
accountability model.
It allows us to see actual
and ongoing progress of English
learners that the English learners
are making within an LEA
and without them the category
of English learners would likely always show
low performance. We also
cannot know whether recent RFIPs
are continuing to progress if
we don't show them for
years out.
It also allows us to understand
English learner development program
the success of that program from
initial identification through initial
years of reclassification.
Two other points that we made back in
September is number four
that including RFIPs
assist with the stability of the student
group and I just wanted to make
a note that since reclassification
is locally determined
by local educational agencies
English learner and RFIP student populations
may have different characteristics
because we don't have this unified
standard and they have
a variety of criteria they can use
to determine reclassified students.
Finally
the
including RFIPs significantly
increases number of schools
and LEAs with a valid end size
to receive a color. So we actually
see a presence of English learner
student groups for
increased number of schools. I think you
may remember from
September it is
over a thousand if not
more than
that that would drop out if
we didn't include the RFIP
student group in the academic indicator.
So we
spent the last couple of weeks
also thinking it would be helpful
to provide an actual example
and so the example I'm going to
show you is
also in the context of when
the Ever Student Succeeds Act first
rolled out and states were considering
their definitions for their
SSA plans. The source
of this example
is from
a blog or a post called
Ending the No Child Left Behind
Catch 22 on
English Learner Progress and we do have
the link to that
report here on this slide.
So I'm going to
actually not spend
time on this. I'm going to show you a graphic
and I'm going to verbally walk through
the points that I have on this slide.
So just to appoint you
to this example
this is a list of 11
students. You can see their names
on the left hand side under the column
student name. We have
two
years of data. I have data
from 2015 for students
and 2016. But I've
actually disaggregated or this
example disaggregates this
by three
columns for the second year of data.
Specifically
this school, this hypothetical
school is known as Middleville.
It was a school
that the instructional program for
English Learners was strong for all
students. As you
can see from column
the column labeled
2015 to the column next to it
which is 2016 with all
scores all students
made gains on their English Language
Arts assessment with an average
score increase of 18 points
from 2015 to 2016.
You can see that in the average
change which is the last
row of
that column three, the column labeled
as 2016
with all scores.
In 2016
two students met the reclassification criteria
Rafael and Irina
the first two students listed.
You see that in
column which is
labeled with numbers.
The third column over
with data which is called 2016
without reclassified students
you can see that they are no longer
applicable to be a part of the
group.
The students were reclassified
because they reached the targeted score
of 350. They were
subsequently removed from the calculations
of the English learner student group.
You see if you scroll down to the
bottom of that column
the average change has now dropped from 18
to negative 5.
Again keeping in mind
that every student
in this school that is an English
learner had actually increased their scores.
Moving over to the final column
there was in
late 2015 after
the assessment was
completed a new student arrived
an immigrant newcomer student
which is Jesse.
Jesse did not have a score in 2015
and we skip over
to that final column
and he received a low score of 90.
The inclusion of the students
score impacted the total
average score of the ELs
to the extent that
it dropped from again starting at
positive 18 to negative
23.
Overall we can see
again this Catch-22 impact
of removing our reclassified
students and only keeping
current ELs in the definition.
Another way of looking at this
is from the overall
scores from year to year
in which we see this same
situation, this same school
just in a graphic form.
So the first two columns here
it says same students, the blue
which is the first column, excuse me
their scores were
257 overall
or rather on average
the second column which is 2016
overall they had
275 average scores.
We shift over to the
second set of data
which is our reclassified students from
removed from the EL group and you see
that shift. You see a shift
from the overall scores for 2015
being higher than the
2016 scores.
So that drop of the five points that
we talked about. The final column
again showing this graphically the impact
of the one newcomer student
and only allowing current ELs in the
definition. So again this is
just a hypothetical example
that was done in preparation
for states considering
English learners and whether or not to
keep our FEPs as part of the definition
for the academic indicator
based on previous experience
from the No Child Left Behind days. So just
wanted to make sure that we provided you
yet another example of
I think why the decision
that the board made back in
the beginning of
the development of the S.S. state plan
is something that still resonates.
So I know this is a little bit of a
complicated conversation. I just
before we shift over to
Josh and a couple of resources I wanted
to make sure President Darling-Hammond
paused in case there were any clarifying questions here.
I am on mute.
Are there any clarifying questions?
Thanks for the
example Cindy.
It shows what different
inferences we would draw
about a school based on this.
Member Escobedo?
I want to share that
I saw this when I
first became superintendent and saw the
transition
that I had
schools that
on purpose
halted reclassification
because of this dip
which could be
very detrimental for students
especially if you're going into middle school
and you're tracked
and you should have been reclassified several
years ago. So
the repercussions of
No Child Left Behind
or the consequences of this
artificial
dip was real
and the effects it had
on student learning
was devastating.
So I just want to share that
yes there's a dip of scores
but how some
schools delayed
reclassification
had a devastating effect on
many of our English learners.
And of course in that accountability
system
this is supposed to let us know
whether a school is doing a good job with
its English learners. You have school
that's doing a really good job with its English learners
looking as though it's
declining
because it is doing
such a good job of reclassifying.
So
that was the catch 22.
Any other
clarifying questions or comments before
Cindy proceeds?
Take it away.
The other
piece that we
did as a takeaway from the September
meeting was that there was a need for
additional resources to support
English learners
for the rollout of the dashboard
in 2022. And so
since your
I feel like I have a little bit of a feedback
here. So since your
agenda was published
those resources have become live
on our website. And so the first
being
how English learners are defined for
each indicator. So you see
on
this screen there's a flyer
that's in purple. Purple is
deliberate because that is the color we're using on
the dashboard this year for status only.
And then each
of the indicators at the state level
are listed that will be used
that are used
on the dashboard. And so you see
a definition for academic
performance, college career readiness,
English learners progress,
chronic absenteeism, graduation
rate and suspension rate.
This is one of the
student groups that has I think one of the more
complex definitions because
of the allowances under again the
Every Student Succeeds Act for
this student group. You can find
this resource on our dashboard toolkit.
You can Google us at CDE
Dashboard Toolkit
and we will be, we're going to be your
top choice. The other
resource that we added was
how to look at English
learners and disaggregate
it for the academic indicator.
And so this is a new resource that
we again developed in direct
response to your discussion
in September. And so you can see
on this graphic that
there is
first there's a card that talks about
English learners and I'm actually showing
off for the first time to you what
our cards are going to look like
for 2022. We are using
a cell phone look.
You can see the low, it has two bars.
Of course if you're at five
bars fully charged
you are
doing great and you're serving your
English learner students well
on the academic indicator. So for this one
it gives you not only
the overall perspective for that
student group for the academic indicator
but then again when we
do view more information we see
that bottom graphic
of the disaggregated data
for current English learners,
reclassified English learners, and
English only. And so
this is one that I
appreciate quite a bit
because often times
while the data on this particular graphic shows
that reclassified English learners
and English only scored exactly the same
amount which is probably impossible
you would usually see our RFEPs
doing actually much better than
any of those student groups. So
again this is another way
of slicing the information
which is something that you specifically asked for.
So both of those flyers are available
again at CDE
Dashboard Toolkit if you're Googling
or on our website under
our toolkit. And with that I would like
to turn it over to Josh Strong to
walk through the remainder of this attachment.
Thank you Cindy.
Good morning
President Erling Hammond,
Vice President Glover Woods,
Chief Deputy Nicely, and
members of the board. I bring you greetings
on behalf of the Director of the
Student Achievement and Support Division
John McGee. He and a number of colleagues
from the division are
down at a conference in San Diego
and Cindy
will catch up with him tomorrow.
So my name is Joshua Strong
I'm the Administrator in the Local
Agency System Support Office here
at the California Department of Education
and I'm bringing you
an update today on the specific
requirements related to English
learners that exist within
the Local Control and Accountability
Plan Template and Instructions.
As all of you
are no doubt aware
in 2013
with the implementation
of LCFF there's
been a requirement for all
LEAs to develop
and annually update the
Local Control and Accountability Plan
or LCAP.
This is something that's done
in
cooperation and
in collaboration with
local educational partners.
Within this annual process
they're evaluating progress
within the
LCFF state priority areas
and they report out
this progress utilizing the template
and instructions adopted
by the State Board of Education.
The
function of the LCAP as
stated within the LCAP
template and instructions is
threefold. It serves as
a comprehensive strategic planning document.
It serves
as to
provide a record
of the meaningful engagement of educational
partners that influence
the development of the plan
and the adjustments made to the plan
and it serves
a role of accountability and compliance
in
including demonstrating
how LEAs are meeting
the requirement to increase or
improve services for
students that are foster youth,
English learners and low income
students.
Within the local control
funding formula
those three student groups are collectively
referred to as the unduplicated
student groups because an
unduplicated count of those
students generates additional
funding.
So going further into this
requirement, the
English learner student group
is one of the three student groups
that generate additional supplemental
funding under the local control
funding formula.
And as a
condition of receiving
these funds, LEAs
are required to include specific
actions within
the LCAP that focus
on increasing or improving
services for their
English learner students as well
as for low income and foster youth
students. Now these
actions are required
to address or
seek to address the
unique identified needs of
the English learner students that
have been identified through a
review of available state
and local data as well
as the input received from
educational partners
in the LEA's community.
That available state data
includes data
from the dashboard, the dashboard
additional reports,
DataQuest, local data
covers a
wide range of information that's
available from
teachers,
from report cards,
from formative assessments
as well as a variety of
other pieces of data
and the engagement from
educational partners includes
teachers, school
staff, administrators
and most importantly parents and students
that are served by
that LEA.
The LCAP is required
to include descriptions
of how these
contributing actions, these actions
that are described as
contributing towards meeting the requirement
to increase or improve services
are in fact
an increase or improve service
as compared to the services that
are being provided to all students
within the LEA during
the school year.
In addition, there are
some other requirements
specific to the English learner
student group.
All LEA's that serve
a numerically significant number
of English learner students, that is
30 or more English learner students
are required to include
additional specific actions
within the LCAP.
At a minimum, those
actions have to address
the language acquisition programs
that are provided to students
by the LEA and
the professional development
activities that are being provided
for staff that
are serving EL students.
And again, that's
required for any LEA
that is serving 30 or more
English learner students.
In addition to
some specific action
requirements,
within the LCAP, there is also
a requirement related to measures of
progress. And
when measuring progress,
LEA's are required to identify
metrics that are going to be used
to track progress.
They're
required to
include specific
metrics that are outlined within
statute.
Related to
priority four, academic achievement,
priority five, student engagement,
and priority six, school climate.
And in addition,
the LCAP template instructions
encourage LEA's to identify
metrics for specific
student groups as appropriate.
Which include
expected outcomes that reflect
growth,
growing any opportunity
or performance gaps that have
been identified within the plan.
Now, it's also worth
noting at this point in time
that within the plan
summary section of the LCAP
at the beginning,
under the identified
need reflection,
LEA's are required to
identify
any performance gaps
or any student
groups that are performing significantly
lower than other
student groups as identified
on the dashboard. And so
2022,
the dashboard for 2022,
will be the first time in the last
few years that we'll actually
have that status
data to inform
the information that's going
to show up within that particular
prompt.
So there are
within statute some specific
measures of
progress related to
the English learner subgroup.
First of all
is the percentage of students
who are English learners
that make progress towards English
proficiency as measured by
the English language proficiency
assessment for California or the LPAC.
And secondly,
the English learner reclassification
rate. However, in addition
to these specific
required metrics,
there's also
a requirement in the
LCAP template that
for state priorities
where there is not
a specific required
metric identified,
the LEA needs
to identify one or more
specific metrics in
order to measure progress relative
to that state priority area.
So for example, in state priority
two,
part of state priority two
is
the extent to
which programs and services
enable English learner students
to access the common core state standards
and the English language development standards
for purposes of gaining academic
content, knowledge, and English
language proficiency.
There is no statutory
specified metric for that
particular requirement
within the state priorities.
Therefore, LEAs are required
to identify
a specific metric of how
they're tracking progress towards
that within the LCAP.
It's also something that needs
to be measured and reported out
as part of the priority
two local indicator
which is reported on
to the public on the dashboard.
In addition,
as part of the template
and as part of the instructions
for the LCAP template, LEAs
are encouraged to use metrics
that are based on and reported through
these self-reflection
tools for local indicators
that are reported on the dashboard.
In each of the
local indicators, LEAs are required
to identify
and measure progress
towards implementing these various
what are referred to as local
indicators within the dashboard
and
that data should
also be used to inform
the development and the annual
update of the LCAP.
In addition,
LEAs are encouraged to focus
on a set of metrics and actions
that the LEA believes
based on input that they've gathered
from educational partners, based
on educational research,
based on experience
either of their LEA or
other LEAs
of those things that will have
the biggest impact on behalf
of their TK through 12th grade
students.
So at this point in time,
I'm going to pause and
I'm going to invite our colleagues
from the Sacramento County Office of Education
to speak with
you on their role
within
supporting the
districts within Sacramento County
as well as the specific
training that they provide
relative to
English learners and
the LCAP development.
Great.
Thank you, Josh.
I'm very honored to
follow CDE's leader, Cindy
Kazanis, Josh Strong, in your presentation.
Good morning, President
Darling Hammond, Vice President
Glover Woods, board members,
CDE staff, board staff.
It's with pleasure that I'm
here today with my colleagues, Kathy
Morrison and Graciela Garcia
Torres from Sacramento County
Office of Education.
We're excited to share with you today
a look at how we support LEAs in our
county in writing LCAP goals and
actions that translate
to effective and impactful
decisions that benefit learners in their
systems. You can go to the
next slide.
So this
morning, in our department
actually at SCOE, we have the
unique pleasure of providing
technical assistance to LEAs through the
development of their LCAPs and
other state plans as well as synthesizing
the information provided by the department
so that it can be applied
thoughtfully and in such a way
that the actions and services directly
impact student outcomes.
We're invited here today
to provide a real life example of
the type of training that county offices
provide that supports
that LCAP development, highlighting
the areas that data
can be used as the plan is created,
especially for English learners.
So I'm going to start by
sharing a bit of background on the Sacramento
County Office of Ed and our
theory of action for our work.
And then Kathy Morrison will outline
how we at SCOE develop
and deliver LCAP professional
learning, and then Graciela will wrap us
up and share the way we approach
supporting LEAs in
understanding and using
EL data and outcomes
to drive improvement. So
just a little bit about
Sacramento County, kind of by the numbers.
We serve
about 250,000
students that are enrolled
in 13 districts and 51
charter schools in Sacramento County.
There's a vast range
of enrollment in those 13 districts
that we serve, from the smallest
being about 246 students
to over 60,000
in the largest district.
So the support that we
provide to LEAs on their LCAP
really varies based on their size and on
each district's capacity.
So for example, in some of our smallest districts
that don't have the same number
of dedicated employees that are working
on pulling in information
and writing that LCAP, we might
provide a more customized support
to them.
And our support
in general is varied.
So we have
monthly meetings. We
provide one-on-one consultation
and small group meetings with similarly
sized or
resourced districts.
We also debrief state-level
trainings, practice data protocols,
and hold writing sessions.
And districts can opt
in and out of those as they need.
Because our
county is widely dispersed geographically,
a bright spot of COVID has been
that we've had greater attendance
because we can use remote applications
for our workshops and travel time
is eliminated, which
makes a big difference for really busy district
leaders. And go to the next slide.
So a little
bit more about our students.
Sacramento County is one of the most
diverse counties in the state.
As you can see, our racial and ethnic
distribution has a nice spread and
students fall into a range of categories.
Those unduplicated categories that
Josh was alluding to earlier
that indicate a greater need in more individualized
supports.
The English learner student population is
around 42,000 students with
almost 30,000
more students that are reclassified as
fluent in our county.
We have a wide diversity of languages
presented. Spanish is the most frequent
language identified with 15%
of EL speakers
are speakers of Spanish.
However, many more languages,
almost 70,
are spoken throughout the county.
So next slide.
Several years ago,
when the Dashboard first
came out, our internal SCOE team
spent some time articulating
a theory of action for how our support
would look and feel for districts.
And our theory of action is here on this slide.
We believe that if we
assist our districts in building their
capacity to improve and identify
practices that ensure every child
has access to a high quality
education and individualized
social and emotional learning supports,
then every child will achieve their greatest
potential in life.
We understand our role
to be more than just LCAP
technical support or providing DA,
but really a coordinated and
connected set of supports
that work together to improve student
experiences and
achievement in schools.
So keeping that ultimate goal
in mind, we've landed on an approach
that we believe works really well.
At the heart of our work is a belief
in continuous improvement where we spend
intentional time reflecting on
how impactful our support is.
And to do that, we take feedback
from our own colleagues
within the county office. We calibrate
with county offices across our region
and the state. And most importantly, we
take and use feedback from our LEAs
that we serve
to ensure that the support we're providing
is really landing for them in a way that
works well for their needs.
Next slide.
So supporting
LEAs in their LCAP development is
a concrete way that districts
and charter schools can communicate their strategic
plans around improving outcomes
for students. The
south LCAP, as you know, is a complex
document, and each one
as the
role of the county office
is really multifaceted. So
we're the support provider, the reviewer,
the approver of each
LCAP. And as we read, we're looking
really to see a through line that starts
with the students reflecting
their successes and challenges that need to be
addressed and really centers the feedback
from a wide array of educational
partners. And then we
learn how the district plans to increase
or improve services for their high need students,
as well as all student
groups that are demonstrating needs, even those
that don't fall into the unduplicated category.
So as we consult
with districts and guide the development of
the LCAP, we remind them to consider student
needs first. We prompt
them by asking questions like
whose needs is the
LCAP designed to serve? What are those
needs? What actions and services have been
effective at addressing those needs?
What needs to be modified
or expanded or re-examined?
Ultimately, our goal
is to adhere to what's written in statute
and Ed code and always seeking
really to operationalize the spirit
of those policies. That is, we're not
the compliance police. Instead,
we want to support our districts
in leveraging documents
like the LCAP to be the entry point
for lasting structural, institutional
and even mindset change
within each system.
At this point, I'm going to turn it over to
Kathy Morrison to share more about
the process and the inputs
that we use to help develop our
LCAP workshops and technical assistance.
So, Kathy.
Good morning, President
Darling-Hammond, members of the State Board
of Education. I'm Kathy Morrison,
coordinator of local
district support services
and accountability
for the Sacramento County Office of
Education.
You can go on, please.
In my role, I plan and
coordinate our county's LCAP
professional development and LCAP review
process. There are a number of
inputs used to develop LCAP
technical assistance.
The foundation is California Education
Code. We follow relevant
legislation and incorporate
enacted policy changes
into our technical assistance.
Most recently, Assembly Bill
1868 established
that reporting process for
English learner achievement data
that includes outcomes
for long-term English learners,
students at risk for
becoming a long-term English learner,
and ELs who have been
reclassified as fluent.
This is our opportunity to highlight
these new data and help our districts
potentially identify areas
of need that can be addressed through the
LCAP. We emphasize
a careful read of the LCAP instructions
as they carry the full force of the law
and attend workshops
and office hours offered by CDE
to understand
the key points that we need to
emphasize. SCOE
is also an anchor
County Office of Education for the
EL RISE Institute.
My colleague Graciela will describe
in a moment how we embed
elements of these materials
into our trainings.
And finally, with our county peers, we attend
workshops offered by the California County
Superintendents Association,
utilize the LCAP review manual,
and participate in those
calibration calls where we share
strategies and best practices.
Next, please.
Shawna mentioned how
we focus on the needs of our users
as we design our workshops.
And that encompasses many things,
district demographics,
data, the resources
they have in terms of staff
and time.
We also reflect on our
prior year's LCAP process
to see if we need to make any adaptations
to scheduling.
For workshops,
whenever possible, we think it's important
to invite participation
from local districts so
there can be some peer-to-peer learning.
And we also
study the
adopted LCAPs.
We note areas that could be strengthened
and then double down on
workshopping our materials to communicate
in multiple ways the content
areas that need to be reinforced.
I want to make a note that our
planning and improvement team is
part of a multidisciplinary
EL RISE initiative
within our county office.
And with this team, we studied
the EL roadmap principles
and we were challenged
to identify an area of improvement
that would
be specific to our locus of control
aligned to one of the principles.
And so our team's
aim is to support and
encourage greater evidence of
disaggregated data for English
learners in LCAPs.
And we are planning now what we might change
in order to see greater evidence
of that data.
Next slide, please.
So on this slide,
we wanted to visualize examples
of how we convey information
in a workshop.
We've been working in a virtual setting for
two and a half years and so we've had to
use some techniques of learning design
that strike a balance between
creating warm and active engagement
for attendees and also
clearly conveying key pieces
of information.
Previously, we've mentioned responding to needs
of our users and the
blue checkmarks that you see here
were included to signify the most
important information.
This was our response
to feedback received on a
prior workshop. A participant
suggested, and this is
a quote, so it's a little awkward,
that we add what's new,
different, that you need
to watch out for so you don't trip
up to address gaps and
red flags that we may experience.
There's a lot to putting together
in LCAP and it's
our belief that
if the basic elements of a presentation
aren't clearly understood,
we must take time to review and
reinforce them.
Next, please.
We believe that our strongest
lever for supporting an
effective and impactful LCAP is working
with the district
staff during the development phase.
That's the time of greatest
influence. We encourage
every district to share their
LCAP in a pre-review.
Some of them will chunk it out.
We then use the California
County Superintendent's
Association LCAP review tool
to indicate where
the district has provided
evidence of meeting requirements
and where they need additional coaching.
We provided a little example
of this type of communication
on this slide.
Finally, we're open to support
LCAP writers in any modality
that works for them in that development
process. We've had drop-in
Zoom office hours,
ad hoc meetings scheduled
to fine-tune specific
LCAP content areas.
With some districts, we just
schedule a regular
bi-weekly or monthly check-in
on the LCAP and other accountability
concerns. And we have
found some success in grouping
meetings by district size
since the needs are so different
based on student enrollment.
Next, please.
This suggested
timeline helps our LEAs
to visualize where
they will need to
be throughout the
LCAP cycle.
For county offices, the release
of the 2022 dashboard
and the data analysis
that our county team will initiate
will set our technical assistance
in motion.
While a mid-year report on the
LCAP is not required,
we continue to encourage
it as a best practice for
reflection and for transparency
with educational partners.
Our English
learner curriculum specialist
is a partner in this process from
designing workshops to LCAP review.
My colleague Graciela
will now provide specific
information about how county offices
encourage and support
the review of data that pertains
to English learners.
Thank you, Kathy.
Good morning. Linda
Darling-Tammon, president of the State
Board of Education and members of the
board. As Kathy said,
my name is Graciela Garcia-Torres
and I am a curriculum specialist
for English learner programs
and accountability for the Sacramento
County. And I'm also a
regional English learner specialist.
In the next slide,
I get to tell you
about our process.
So as our county office
of education English learner specialist
and English learner need for region
three, these are inputs
that inform my work. The collaboration
among the regional English
learner specialist alongside the California
Department of Ed Multilingual
Support Division to make
meaning of the legislation is essential
to this process.
The bilingual coordinators network
and the luncheon
complement and complete the required
information so that then we can go ahead and
share the adjusting time
of the legislation and make meaning
and make it relevant
for our districts and in the LCAP
process. As the regional lead,
I have reached to 10 other counties
to provide the same
resources and information
throughout the regional network,
the multilingual education leadership
network. And I am able to
gather this information
through the regional English
learner specialist and the VC
and the bilingual coordinators network and
infuse it in the regional
network. For the last two years,
the Sacramento County Office of Education has
been in collaboration
with EL Rice, the English learner roadmap
implementation for systemic excellence
serving as an
county, as Cathy said, to implement
the English learner roadmap
policy. And through this
education workforce
investment grant, or the
IWA, we have offered
the English learner roadmap Align
LCAP toolkit using the
research-based tools to
promote equity for English learners.
Part of our internal process
with EL Rice has been
to convene an internal team.
And we have
15 different cross-collaborative
departments making
meaning of the services and programs
for English learners
based on their context.
And as Cathy mentioned, each
one of these departments is involved in
a plan, do, study, act
cycle of improvement. They reflect
upon the change ideas
to better serve English learners and
understand the principles of the English
learner roadmap. And that is part
of our process. In the next slide,
you can see that
being part of the Sacramento County
Office of Education, LCAP
technical assistance and workshops,
office hours, and continued
collaboration with our
planning improvement team is an
essential aspect to support
the English learners in our county.
Assisting
our districts in building their
capacity to improve
and identify practices
that ensure that every student
that are English learners have access
to a high quality education
and do as best possible
to individualize that social, emotional
and learning supports
is important. We use
tools to offer the
equitable opportunity to achieve
our theory of action
so that educators can also
have these tools. We see
the requirements of the LCAP
for English learners not as
an isolated areas
but as interconnected concepts.
The implementation of the
EOD standards, the content standards,
the English learner data,
the professional development and
the program descriptions are to
build upon each other and connect.
So what does that story
say when we look at the data?
What does it say in terms of
what our students need?
What does the English learner
progress indicator
say in terms of the student achievement
in language acquisition? And then
what do we know about our
reclassified fluent English proficient
existing data
and how successful are we providing
access to the content and that continued
monitoring and that
access to the content for our English learners
in achieving language acquisition.
So these tools
that we provide is
a process of
understanding at a deeper level.
In the next slide you see one of
these tools and resources
and so the
Loyola Marymount University Center for
Equity for English learners in
the Californians together provide professional
development and the
resources for educators,
families and community members.
Through the EO Rise we have
offered multiple sessions as
an option for our districts to be
part of and attend and engaged.
We feel that this ensures that the LCAP
reflects how actions and services
and programs and
resources are made available
for equitable opportunities
and outcomes for our English learners.
These resources have
focus areas and rubrics
that are research-based and
can infuse practices
that
center on our English learners
and achieve those intended
gains. In the next slide
we see an example
of what is found
in this toolkit. You see the
six focus areas are called
out in this toolkit that
provide the frame to dig
deeper into how well we are
focused in these actions,
resources and that are requiring
the LCAP. As you
can tell these areas reflect
the requirements of the LCAP specifically
calling out English learners, student
group. So one
of those tools is in the next slide.
And
as you can see here,
here's an example of the focus area
in the rubric to
describe the professional development.
These rubrics show
and serve
as a guide and a reminder
of what is effective
and what is that
implementation
level that we need to see in that
aspect of language
that we can use as
we are making these plans.
Districts are encouraged to use
these rubrics and to use the language
to support them in the
process.
We strongly agree with
the concept that we
rather have influence in the
development of the LCAP rather
than making corrections during
the review. In the next
slide you're
going to see
this data. You might have seen
this before. I was very pleased
to hear about the new resource
on disaggregated data for academic
indicator. This is an example
of what that means.
This data came from the Loyola
Marrow Mound California
Californians Together presentation.
And it is a part of the
Californians Together
framework for an effective
and coherent accountability system for
English learners. As you can see, it
shows the importance of pulling out
the varied outcomes for reclassified
English learners
in comparison to the
English learners.
This is the 2019
dashboard data showing the results
for the academic indicator for
English language arts. The subgroup
is English learner for
districts that have 30 or more
students and that
they had a performance
level in California.
The first pie is this
indicator. We are looking for
blue and green.
So we see some blue,
a little bit of blue, and a little bit more
of green. When you see the
equation, the equate
to the next two pies, you see
the reclassified
English proficient students take the green
and the blue. And you don't see that
with the English learners. So this
is an aspect of
us encouraging our districts
to disaggregate that data, especially
locally having more
opportunities to see that data
more widely.
And so we feel that a critical
focus on English learners is not
only about the performance level, but
also that progress
and that celebrating the success of the
reclassified English
proficient students is just as
important as celebrating and
adequately reflecting the needs of
our English learner-only
student group. And
finally, in this
last slide that I have,
is just, you know,
an example of what
it looks like at a district
level, this kind of data.
As a county, we suggest to our districts
the importance of disaggregating
the academic indicator
for ELA and mathematics.
Again, this example is a district
not in Sacramento, like I said, and it
shows how the data,
once disaggregated, behaves
with the purpose to have a better
picture of the needs of the reclassified
students as they are being monitored,
as well as the English learners that
they are in need of accessing
content and acquiring the English
language in the comparison
of their English-only peers.
We feel that this practice
is important for the continuous
improvement and responsive needs
plans to be implemented.
It also provides a
more accurate picture
for their educational partners
and opportunities to affect
relevant, increased,
or improved services.
The California Schools dashboard
provides the mathematics and
English language arts data comparisons
for English learners.
We encourage
our districts to reflect
this in their LCAPs,
and in the recent years,
we have seen more of our districts
include the comparative data
in their plans.
And with that, I will now turn it over
to Dr. Cook to share
how we plan to move forward
with the LCAP development.
Great. Thank you, Graciela.
So, you know, kind of looking ahead,
you know, given this moment in time
as we look forward to a new
dashboard and as we kind of emerge
from these last two
COVID years, so to speak,
I don't know if we're emerging. I'm
actually recovering from COVID
right now, so it's still very much
here. But we're really
taking to heart actually
dashboard principle 10 that was just
discussed that really promotes
coherence between data
reporting and support
and improvement programs.
You know, the dashboard,
the LCAP process, the system
of support all work together to identify
and address areas of performance
that need to improve
so that all interested parties
can understand and work towards
consensus
on the improvement priorities for
a district and its schools.
The review of these indicator
data is embedded into
the annual processes that drive goal
setting, outcome actions, and expenditures
in every district in California.
And really what that looks like for us
in our county is a continued collaboration
with county office partners
and advocacy groups to
enhance our work.
And within our own county office,
a continued cross-departmental collaboration
to deepen our implementation.
And that really means
looking at curriculum and instruction,
LCAP, data and assessment, expanded
learning, early learning, social-emotional
learning, the list goes on and on.
And really kind of making sure that we
stay organized and connected in such
a way that our support to districts
and charter schools in our
county is coherent, cohesive,
and useful
at helping districts
and systems really get at
improving outcomes for students. So I
guess with that, thank you
for your time today. We hope
that this presentation has provided
a little glimpse into how
we provide guidance and support
to LEAs in our county.
And in particular, supporting
and improving English learner outcomes.
And that's
it for us. Is there any
questions?
I think we can
proceed on. I think there's
maybe still part of the item left
to present. Thank you
so much.
Josh, are you there to
present the next part of the item?
Good morning. We still have a couple
minutes left before morning. I'm going to
get you through this so you can
start your deliberations.
Just to close this out, we
have been busy this year, and
I predict very
soon, by the end of the month, we will hit 10,000
participants in our presentations
for the year. We
spent really the spring
and summer preparing for
this fall, and so this gives you just
a high-level overview
of how much outreach we've been doing.
But more importantly, on
this next slide, we have
a webinar series that we launched
this Tuesday. We copied
really Josh does these Tuesdays
at 2. We're doing Tuesdays at 2 in
November. In December, he's going to pick
up the Tuesdays at 2. We had
close to 1,000 people on that webinar,
which talked about
just introduction to the Dashboard.
Kimberly Munhink, who's on
the Zoom today and is supporting
us from
Anaheim at the California Education
Research Conference, her team, along
with many others, not only in my division,
but really throughout
the department who assist us,
we've really
benefited from this collaborative effort to
make sure we are prepared as
possible to continue to support the field
once the Dashboard is live
in December.
One thing I wanted to mention is
a presentation Kim did today
with the Los Angeles County Office of
Education around
looking at how to support
LEAs, look at their results in the
Dashboard. And I think
one thing is that we need to keep in mind
LEAs are talking
and serving students every single day.
The state and this Dashboard
gets produced once a year. And so
we're really looking in a rear view mirror
and really the true work
happens on a daily basis
with a teacher serving
students and helping to
impact their lives and
their future. And so we are so grateful
for this
large system, not only of support,
but around accountability, around
data reporting, and
we are prepared for a release,
like I mentioned in December.
One thing I also wanted to just say
in passing is we have
because we are in our busy time,
we've been delayed on some other reports, but one
piece of data we got out this week was
updating our college going rate reports.
So for those of you that really
are paying attention to high schools,
this is a report that we've only been able
to do with some additional
funding for National Student Clearinghouse
data. And so that is
a match set that
we have not updated in two years. So I'm really excited
that that data is out there.
It does not contribute to accountability.
It does not contribute to assessments, but it simply
provides a perspective on students
who are able to
enroll in our public
institutions and private
institutions of higher education in California,
including our community college system.
So with that,
the recommendation is that the CDE
recommends approval of the California
School Dashboard principles.
Terrific. Thank you so much.
At this point, we do want to put up
the public comment
line slide.
We'll open the phone line for public comment.
Members of the public wishing to provide
public comment on this item may do
so by calling the telephone number and
using the access code provided on the
slide that is shown now.
And while we're waiting, I want to ask our liaison
Vice President Glover-Woods if she has
any initial comments before me.
Then I'll ask board members if they have
any clarifying questions on
factual points before we go to public
comment, which will be followed
by board discussion.
And so
let's see if
Vice President Glover-Woods
You are, I'm not hearing you.
Vice President Glover-Woods is
not coming through on this end either.
Yeah, we're not able
to hear you. There may be something wrong with
your audio.
Okay.
So we'll come back to you.
Very
good. Are there any clarifying
questions on matters of fact
from the board before
we go to public comment?
And I am not
seeing any at the moment.
That's a good thing because we stand between
ourselves and lunch.
Hopefully everything is crystal
clear. We will now
see if there is any public comment.
We have
13 callers on the queue. I will open
up the phone line now.
Good afternoon. Please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts
now.
Caller ending in the last four digits,
4450, you are now live. Please
start your public comment.
I'm Lauren Johnson, Mount
Gavreau Unified School District.
In Kern County
with a population of
36,544
English learners, no districts
are required to include a goal
for ELs in their LCAP.
Without including a goal
with accompanying actions and
services, the equitable
allocation of funds by these students
is not consistent with the dashboard
principle 10 calling for
coherence between data
reporting and support and
improvement programs.
The ELPI
suggested English learners
in only two districts out of
48 are not making adequate
progress for learning English
and only two districts are eligible
for support through differentiated
assistance.
We question whether only holding two
districts accountable for progress
and learning English and two for
additional support through
DA represents the true needs in a
community with large numbers of
English learners.
We treat each component of the accountability
system to better represent
what should be the approach for
uplifting the needs of ELs.
Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time
starts now.
Good afternoon.
This is Jessica Sacco on behalf
of Children Now calling in
to the proposed dashboard
principle. I'd like to thank
the department staff for
opening the doors of conversation
with the LCFF equity coalition
and for being so responsive
to many of our suggestions
and engaging in deep
conversation. I'd like to focus
specifically around encouraging
around principle
number one.
We feel that this
particular principle does not
exemplify what we consider to be
current practice and therefore we
are in full support of
this principle as we
believe and we encourage
you to add well-rounded to
that principle. For principle
number two, our
concern is that the LCFF, excuse me,
the equity report simply reports
a particular student group's place in
relation to a standard but not in relation
to other student groups therefore making
a view of the achievement gap
a lot more challenging.
For principles three and four,
we've included in our letter
an attachment for details about how the
current rating system favors some indicators
over others in identifying
LEAs for district assistance
and we strongly support
and want to
state that we strongly support a
multiple measures accountability system.
We do have
concerns about the use of the term
equally.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, Peter
Ahern, President of the California Association
of Science Educators, speaking on behalf of
a large coalition of science educators
and organizations. We support the
change to dashboard principle three to
say it reports each indicator separately
since this helps resolve concerns
about how indicators are weighted.
We wonder if the language
in the new dashboard indicator number four
that says values each indicator
equally could be amended to say
values each indicator since the word
equally could bring back the concern about
weighting unnecessarily.
The point of the dashboard is that showing many
indicators gives a fuller picture of a school's
performance. It's really up to parents
the community and students to decide which are
most important to them. The word
equally doesn't add anything and implies
weighting. We hope these changes
will help resolve some technical issues around
science being added to the dashboard.
We look forward to science being on the dashboard
next year once we have two years of
valid and reliable data.
Thank you. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and
affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, this is Manuel
Blancosta, Associate Director of Policy at California
and I'm calling to raise
our ongoing concern about our current
accountability system, hiding
outcomes for English learners.
This is especially apparent when we look at our
secondary students.
This is of critical importance given that
nearly half of secondary English learners
are long-term English learners.
This means that half of our secondary
ELs are in a system that has failed
to meet them along their journey
towards English language proficiency.
We are encouraged
to hear the September State Board of Education
meeting and Dr. Hammond
referenced a possible need to see how
long-term English learners might be
addressed within the state accountability system.
And we fully support the State Board of
Education looking for the answers.
In particular,
measuring and setting goals for districts
to reduce the proportion of their secondary
English learners who are long-term
English learners might be a possible
case to look at, very similar to the goals
that we set for
expulsion rates
and other similar measures.
Thank you again for looking into
accountability for English learners
and especially making sure that we're
addressing the specific needs of
the different types of English learners
that are in our system, in particular
our long-term English learners. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi.
My name is Martha Martinez
and I am from SEALS, the broader early
academic language, and I want to thank
the State Board of Education members
for your attempts to create an accountability
system that promotes a more equitable
education system.
Unfortunately, the current dashboard and
accountability measures are not consistent
with the principles we are adopting today,
in particular principle 2.
The current system obscures the performance
and needs of English learners
and sets performance standards for
English learners that are too low.
Over half of the state's current
ELs are either long-term
English learners or they are at risk
of becoming an ELTEL.
However, the state's current proposal would only
require two districts to include a goal
for English learners in their LCAP
and would identify less than 1%
of English learners as not
making sufficient progress in learning English.
I strongly encourage you
to consider the unintended
consequences from the current accountability
approach and to develop an alternative
approach, including convening
a workgroup to help you identify
accountability metrics that will promote
equity for all students, including
English learners. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Greetings, Madam President
and State Board members. My name is
Vanessa Calderon, Assistant Principal
at Chano Inns High School in Oxnard, California.
There are 16,043
English learners enrolling
schools in the Ontario Valley.
They constitute 43 of all students
in this county. No school
is identified for SEI
or ATSI. No
district has to include a goal for
their English learners in their LCAP
and only one district was identified for
extra support to differentiated assistance.
One would assume that the
English learners are doing well, but the
CAS data that was just presented does
not indicate that. So how do
these decisions based upon the data
from the dashboard align with principles
two, five, and six?
The low expectation of the CAS score
for ELPI did not identify one
district, the very low in performance
level. We should be considered looking
at the alignment of the results
seen from the data on the
dashboard and the needs of English learners.
And what can the systems
do to make the needs
of English learners visible and
optionable? We need your support and
guidance to make these critical adjustments.
Thank you. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts
now.
My name is Jenny Snyder calling on
behalf of the California County Superintendents
to support the CDE's
proposed changes to the dashboard
principles. We express our deep
gratitude to Cindy
Kazanis and her team for providing
ample opportunities for all educational
partners to weigh in and
incorporating our input.
We would also like to thank
the Local Agency Systems Support
Office and the Sacramento County Office
of Education for such comprehensive
presentations on the current
requirements in place to support
California's English learners through the
LCAP process.
The work of improving outcomes for our English
learners is a shared responsibility.
The California County Superintendents
have found great value in the professional
learning and technical assistance provided
through the System of Support Educator
Workforce Investment grant
provided by our colleagues
Calhoug and Covey.
With their support,
county offices support their local districts
to utilize the LCAP process
to operationalize equity
and improve systems to better support
our English learners.
Finally, if the state were to consider
making any changes to the LCAP,
we respectfully request that
no changes are implemented outside
of the first year of the new
three-year cycle. Thank you.
Thank you.
Mox Collar, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello. Patty Chavez with
SEAL and joining Calhoug Partners today.
We appreciate the set of data
dashboard principles and specifically
the intention of coding gaps across
the indicators. We believe it's appropriate
to revisit the results
and implications of the indicators
and their alignment to the dashboard principles.
Many lessons can be drawn from
the data that today's speakers have
and will share. We are glad
to be learning from past initiatives where
there has been unintended yet
detrimental consequences for EL.
The current accountability
system addressed many of the problems with
the use of multiple measures. The
move away from hitting targets to status
and change, however, is overcorrected
and now very few districts are
identified to receive differentiated
assistance. We
urge the board to make this time to revisit
how the academic indicator
LP, DEA, TSI,
and ASSI are structured
and how they can be revised
to address the needs of EL.
We welcome an opportunity for us to engage
to work together to partner with you and
staff. We thank you very much for your
dedication. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time
starts now.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Dr. Jose Hugo Moreno, Director of
Parental Relations for Calvary California Association
of Bilingual Education, school
administrator and university professor. Sharing with
you that in Alameda County, only one
school district out of 18 has
to include a goal for English learners
in the LCAP. Keep in mind
that the county enrolls 43,000
English learners in only one district, which is
5% of the districts need to address the growth
of English language proficiency for these students,
our students. The accountability
system only identifies two districts, or
10% out of 18, that are eligible
for additional support.
To differentiate assistance, the issue of
transparency addressed in principle six speaks to
the need to shine a light on language and
academic needs of English learners.
I think we all agree that with the numbers
of English learners in Alameda County, we need
to evaluate the transparency of the accountability
system, and the criteria for requiring both actions
and services for English learners.
With only one district required to include
a goal for English learners,
the visibility of thousands of English learners
is met. These are our students,
our future citizens of the state
and the nation. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller,
please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello,
I'm Sally Fox, representing
the California Association for Bilingual Education.
I'm also a retiree from
the San Diego County Office of Education,
where an EL data dashboard was
developed to support leaders of our
42 county school districts make
better decisions. The
SCCLE dashboard makes more specified
or specific data
visible for districts, thereby providing
more meaningful information to truly
reveal EL needs.
The latest iteration of SCCLE's tool
reveals student learning trajectories
related to English language acquisition
and allows educators to drill
through reporting to individual student
level profiles. This humanizes
the data so educators may better
understand the strengths and needs
of their students. Our current state
dashboard indicators are not complete
enough to require any districts in
San Diego County and only two
statewide to include a goal for
ELs and ELPAC, which questions
the alignment of the dashboard for
school districts. When considering the process of
continuous improvement for the state
dashboard, SCCLE dashboard
may be a good model to consider.
Thank you. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and
affiliation for the record. You have one minute, your
time starts now.
Yes, President Darling
Hannon and members, Shelly Siegel
Coleman from Californians Together.
For the 2021-24
ELPAC, only two districts
are required to include a goal for English
learners. Dr. Hakuta explained
that the EL aggregate score
gives the best representation of a district
EL program from initial
English learners to
reclassification. We disagree.
For example, one
large urban school district with a large
EL population, not
a port of entry district, has an
ELA EL performance level of
yellow, suggesting they're doing okay.
But their current ELs
are red. 60% of
other districts across the state are
orange and yellow, indicating room for
improvement. Their RFPs
are yellow. 58%
of other districts are green or blue.
Again, room for improvement.
The dashboard suggests there's no
need to address either of these groups
in their ELCAS. With Principle 11
calling out dashboard continuous
revision and improvement, we are
eager to collaborate with you
on this work. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your
name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, board
members. John Effelt from Public
Advocate. Along with
the Equity Coalition, we urge the board
to better identify for support
and assistance all the LEAs
that are not making adequate
progress with your ELs
in at least two ways. First,
refine the trigger for determining
which LEAs should be in
differentiated systems based on
their EL performance. Ideas
worth studying include
building an individual student growth
data when those scores become available,
reducing the number
of years of RFPs in the measure,
separating the LP out
as its own state indicator,
and or adding an
LTAL component to the model.
This work should be part of the dashboard
work plan for 2023.
Second, modify
the LCAP so that more LEAs
are required to establish separate
goals, actions, and metrics for
low-performance student subgroups
and not just those in differentiated
systems. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please
state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one
minute. Your time starts now.
Hello. This is Linda
Kaminsky. I'm the director of research and policy
at the Center for Equity for English Learners
at Loyola Marymount University.
To achieve equity,
we must focus on closing opportunity
and achievement gaps.
Yet our most recent LCAP report
by the Center for Equity for English Learners
looked at 26 districts serving
1,000 or more
English learners, which was 50 percent or
more, and found that out of all
those 26, only five
had metrics or desired outcomes
for English learners. Yet these
outcomes were not differentiated for
ELs. For example,
one area that was concerned
was high school blackout rates, with
a goal of decreasing that by 3 percent,
but 3 percent for both
all students and for ELs,
but essentially that doesn't
close the gap because the ELs
had double the rate of the dropouts.
Equity requires
closing gaps. Closing
gaps requires an accountability
system that is based on
differentiated targets as well as
the action, services, and support needed
to achieve these differentiated targets.
Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state
your name and affiliation for the record. You have one
minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
President Darlingham
and members, Liz Guiano, public
advocate, also for the Equity Coalition.
We appreciate the revisions
to the guiding principles, but don't
agree that the current practice and the dashboard
actually reflects the new language.
We recommend that aligning
this assignment be added to the
department's work time for 23.
The EL and LCAT
presentations today were really strong,
the ones that Josh and
the Scully team gave. We recommend
that these presentations be a separate
webinar to the benefit of LEAs, including
other county offices of Ed.
This was a much deeper dive that
LEAs obviously need.
Gap closing goals and metrics should be required
for student groups that are performing substantially
below white, non-low-income,
English-only student groups.
The board and administration should
consider strengthening this
demonstration in the LCAP in the January
budget. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state
your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. This is Sarah
Lillis with Peach Plus. I also
want to share my appreciation for the board
and staff and hearing and being so responsive
to our feedback on the dashboard
principle. We're really thrilled
with the changes that were made, particularly
as it relates to principle two, and we
look forward to the evolution
of the dashboard to better reflect the
focus on gaps and gap closure as
discussed by my colleagues and children now
and the focus on gaps on the equity
report. We also want to reiterate
the
new principle four. We appreciate that
we need to articulate valuing
all of the indicators. We would
also recommend removing the word
equally because of the potential
unintended consequences in terms of
weighting as we think about equal
value. Thank you again for all your
work on this. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time
starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Lucero Chavez,
Director of Policy and Partnerships
who is speaking at the Parent Institute for
Quality Education. Today we urge you to
take a closer look at how the data
dashboard principles are translated when
addressing the needs of English learners.
We're grateful for the data dashboard
principles for upholding high
performance standards and accuracy
reporting. However, statistics
aren't required to include the goals
for EL students in the LCAP. We're
missing out on important data that could inform
much needed intervention for students,
especially after the learning loss
occurred during the pandemic.
Parents, including BGIP parents of
English learners, are eager to engage with
their schools to support their students' academic
achievements. The families need data
on their students' growth and clear,
ambitious goals that our English learners can work
towards. Thank you, and we look
forward to working together for the success of EL
and the California family.
Thank you. Next caller,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have
one minute. Your time starts now.
Yes, Sandy Mendoza,
Families and Schools.
Los Angeles County involves
247,699
English learners.
Narrative from the data
chart,
that's what that shows.
How is it possible that there are
no districts that are required to have a
goal in the LCAP for English learners
and that every EL student in the
80 districts in the county are
making adequate decisions?
In the county are making adequate
progress in learning English.
Differentiated assistance should
be supporting the closing of gaps for
student subgroups of state and
principal too, but our current
system of support only identifies
three out of 80 districts needing
support for their English learners.
This is not an accurate picture
of what is needed across districts in
vibrant and diverse counties.
Please review each component of the accountability
system to better represent
what should be the approach for
uplifting the needs of ELs which
is aligned to principal 11.
Thank you so much.
Thank you. Next caller, please state
your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
My name is Dr. Al Macasso
from California Association
for Bilingual Education,
SCRAB-A, Multilingual California
Project. I'm also a
board member for Limwood Unified School District
and University Professor in
South State Long Beach.
As a professor involved in future preparation,
we look at the dashboard for
data to look at their individual districts
and classes.
Here our students find
the growth of their English learners.
The data provided is not
transparent, but misinforming
our candidates of the actual needs
of the students, minimizing the actual
growth that should occur.
When looking at the LCAP,
students are often dismayed
at the lack of goals and metrics
for growth for English learners.
We take our candidates to have
high expectations, as described
in principal five, and also
to create an advocacy program
in the classroom. However, the
low expectations promoted for growth
on the LCAP are
not the needs of our current
English learners in the academic indicators
of confusing and leave our
students with many questions.
Today I encourage you to consider
looking at the indicators on the dashboard
and enhancing LCAP metrics.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
My name is Eduardo Munoz, and I'm a professor
at San Jose State University, where
I am also a coordinator of a bilingual
program, and I am supporting the
point being made by California's Together.
Santa Clara County enrolls over
54,000 ELs,
making up nearly one in four students.
However, none of the districts
in the country were required to write
goals for EL-CAPs, and
none would be identified
based on the low expectations that are
set by the ELP. Moreover,
only two of the 31 districts
were identified for differentiated
assistance based on EL performance,
and just six schools
were identified for additional
targeted support and improvement
for EL performance.
This information should cause us to want to
take a look at the alignment of the results
from the data on the dashboard
to the needs of English learners, and what
can the system do to make the needs of
English learners visible and actionable?
How is it possible that
these students are not getting support?
These organizations, these LEAs,
are not being identified for support
in the light of these results.
We need your help and guidance
to make these critical adjustments.
Thank you very much for your time.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Dr. Krista Kaban,
and I'm an educator at Glendale High School,
teaching 175 9th
and 10th grade ELB students.
Half of my students are considered long-term
English learners or at risk of becoming one.
This is a significant number of students
who reflect members across the state of California.
It has led to a widening
achievement gap between this group of students
and their peers. The current system
hides outcomes for ELB, especially our
secondary students. Through my doctoral
and field work, long-term English learners
have also mentioned not understanding
the pathway towards reclassification
and felt a stigma patch of label.
We need an accountability system that will
no longer make these students invisible.
Now that the governor has signed AB 1868,
we hope that as the
accountability system is reviewed,
we might find a way to ensure that meeting the needs
of ELB health is incorporated.
Thank you for listening. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time
starts now.
Hi, my name is Robert Manwearing
from Children Now. We'd like to associate
ourselves with the comments of
CalTOG, the Equity Coalition,
and public advocates around the
AL issues raised today.
I wanted to add one more issue
to the plate. Specifically, we'd
like to see a 12th principle
added that would state something to the effect
of additional state and local
indicators may be added to the dashboard
that support LCFF
state priorities. The reason
we think this additional
principle is needed is
when you look at the interaction
of the valuing
indicators equally principal,
which is number four, and the
requirements of ESSA around
weighting of indicators, it seems
like it might create a barrier to
adding additional indicators like
science or a growth model
or currently high school chronic
absence rates,
which has already been banned from the
dashboard because of this interaction
or teacher assessment.
So we'd like you to take a deeper look at
the weighting of indicators
and how additional indicators
could be added in the future. Thank you
so much. Thank you.
That concludes public comment for item
number 13.
Thank you so much,
and I want to give Vice President
Glover Woods an opportunity to
frame some comments before we get
started on our discussion.
Okay, thank you. Can you hear me?
No? Yay. All right.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, President Valenzuela.
And thank you to all those who
called in. Just a couple of framing
comments before we
continue into our discussion.
Along the line
of, again, giving thanks,
much thanks to all of the
educational partners and the
CPAC members for giving
feedback on the dashboard principles
and for CDE for taking all of that
feedback along with the feedback
from this board to
revamp and revise
the principles. I think one of the key
pieces is understanding
that these principles, as was
suggested in the presentation,
will continue to come back
for review, continue to come back
for revisions that may be needed
as time evolves. So
quite excited about that.
There is something in our
current draft of
principles that I would like to point
out and ask that we make
an adjustment to, and that
is the use of the word
accountability system or system
in the areas where it
should really refer to dashboard
because these principles
that are before us for approval
are in relation to
the dashboard. The accountability
system, of course, is a much larger
entity
of which the dashboard is one
component. So I
will bring it forward in a motion, but
I just want to bring this forward for
consideration of the board, which
is that in principles
1, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, and 11
would be appropriate
to replace the words accountability
system and system
with the word dashboard
so that, again, the principles
align and the language
in each of the principles aligns
to the dashboard
itself. So, again, just wanted to
point that out. Just
another comment or two
before we continue with our
discussion, which is in
relation to the
LCAP requirements for English
learners and how
it is to be reflected in the
LCAP. As Josh Strong
went through, and I can say also as
a former county office administrator, I
know that the requirement
for the needs of
English learners to be addressed in
the LCAP are quite
extensive, and these are not
may-dos, if you will, but
must-dos because our English
learners are part of the unduplicated
people group that generates
supplemental dollars.
So actions and services
for increased actions,
increased supports
and services, I should say,
are to be reflected in the LCAP. So
concerned with many of
the communications that we've received
in our box as well as what we've
heard in public comment, I'm going
to need a little bit of clarification as
to how these requirements are in place,
but yet it's
being said that
there are no LCAP goals
for LEAs in such
an extensive manner across the state.
One other
aspect I just want to point out
for conversation
is that
the majority of county
offices do go through a quite extensive
process providing
professional support
to LEAs on the
development of their LCAP as well as
the review of the
LCAP itself, and there's
a lot of work done through
the California County Superintendents
Association, particularly
the Curriculum Instruction Steering
Committee, to ensure calibration
across the state.
So as was stated in one of the
comments we heard during our public
comment period, we had a wonderful
example from the Sacramento
County Office of Education.
We know there are county offices of education
that are really going through quite an
extensive way and providing a lot of
important information
to LEAs on how to look at
the needs of English learners and how to
reflect that and also look at disaggregating
that data. I also
would suggest that we
look at those models and
continue to share those
models across the state for
those that might
still be wondering how to best
make sure that English learners
and the needs of our English learners at all
different levels are actually being
addressed. I believe
at this point that concludes
any framing comments that I might
have, and I'll save anything else
I have for our ongoing discussion.
Thank you.
And I am the other liaison
for accountability, so I have a few
framing comments and then I see we have
discussion pending with
some board members ready to dive in.
I also want to just thank the
department for providing all of
the many slices of English learner data.
And I think
the issue that we're
surfacing and that we want
to come back and deal with
is the fact that
what is not a trigger
right now for
LCAP attention
is the
progress of English learners as it is
reflected in the LP data
and in the
at-risk and long-term
English learner data. Those are
available to people, but we do not
currently have a requirement
that they be
a basis for
planning and investing.
And so I'd love for our
department staff to come back
to us in the next meeting.
And as we're thinking about how to
start a new three-year
LCAP cycle in 2024,
we need to plan for any changes
in the LCAP now.
I'd like us to take the opportunity
to take a look at the LCAP instructions,
provide recommendations to the
board on where they could be strengthened
to ensure that a deep data analysis
around
LCAP planning for English learners
includes LTELs
and at-risk of long-term
English learner status
and a look at the progress
that is shown in the LP indicator.
We got started on this, and we
started the conversation today about
how the
Department of Education in Washington had
created a category and then
used that category for accountability
in ways that were
problematic because
districts making
very strong gains using
the definitions that were required
could be put into
sanctions, could have schools
closed, could have teachers,
staff reconstituted,
even as they were making good progress because
the indicator itself
was badly constructed for the
purpose of seeing whether a district
was helping its learners
progress. But we have another
need,
we've redefined that category,
but we have another need, which is to have
an indicator really looked at
for the LCAP
that shows progression
directly for LPs
and for students who may be at risk
of long-term English learners.
I'd also like to ask the 2023
dashboard work plan to
include work that will strengthen our reporting
on the English learner student
group, specifically those
categories that I've just identified
and I hope we'll come back
and be able to take a look at that.
On the
principles, we've heard a lot
of good ideas for wordsmithing
the principles. We just heard
from Vice President Glover Woods
the proposal to be clear about
the fact that they pertain to the
dashboard and not the entire
accountability system. We heard
from public comment and from some of
the letters the
I think valuable idea
to delete the term
equally from principle four because it
still can be misread
and perhaps to introduce the term
well-rounded into principle one
which I think reflects our goals
so I would like to just
pre-offer
those ideas
as well as we take up the principles.
We do have a commitment
from the department to bring those back every
year so if we
can enact something
today with some
of the wordsmithing we can continue
to work with the department on those
in the future.
And so now I know that
Member Escobedo and Member Arrozco-Gonzalez
are ready to dive in.
Member Escobedo, do you want to start your hand
up first? Yes, I just
pretty much
wanted to emphasize the importance
of following long-term
ELs as well as
at-risk which you beautifully
stated and also
ensure even though
I heard from Dr.
Glover-Woods that counties
do calibrate themselves
I just want to make
sure that
they're also
utilizing similar resources such
as EL Rise that I think
is a great roadmap to
follow and I know Sacramento
uses it as an anchor
so I just hope also
the assistance
comes from
a similar source as well.
So just wanted to share
those two points.
Thank you. Member Arrozco-Gonzalez?
Thank you.
I want to thank
Vice President Glover-Woods
for saying that the principles are malleable
and could be revisited.
I think that I heard
quite a bit of the callers including
the California Association of Science
asking about the language
of principle four that states
the values of each indicator
equally and I know you
mentioned also
Vice President Darling-Hammond
about looking into the words
of that indicator since
the word equally brings back concerns
about weight unnecessarily.
So I think the equal weighting approach
could result in unintended consequences
so maybe revisiting the language
on that principle.
And also I want to mention
about how we are a highly
multilingual state and we need
to make sure that the support is available
in particular for English learners.
With the revision of the principles
I see an opportunity for us
to review the consequences of the
indicators and the alignment
to the principles. I would suggest
the CDE include in their accountability
work plan a review of the impact
of the current academic indicator,
the cut scores of the LPI,
and the criteria requiring districts to
include go for student subgroups
in their LCAP.
And now is the time to look for
a 2023 dashboard
and it would be good to see
the options for next year.
Terrific. So I think we're going to
have a meaty conversation in our next
meeting about how we can
address the
English learner indicators.
Knowing that we
Yes, would you like to
Just to clarify,
your next meeting that we will be presenting
at is March.
We will not be able to come in January
because we're going to be putting out a dashboard
in December. So I just want to make sure
as far as timing goes that we're on the same
page for when
you will see an accountability item
around the dashboard.
Okay.
As soon as we can,
we want to all deliver
speed to begin
considering these alternatives
so that we can learn what's possible.
Absolutely. Thank you.
So I would like to, because
we know that that's an important issue
and we've heard from board members and
the public that we need to address it,
put that
to our next opportunity
to have that conversation and
focus in on the item that we need to
consider for approval,
which is the dashboard principles.
And
what I've
heard thus far is
several potential small
amendments to the principles,
which maybe Vice President
Glover Woods is about to summarize
for us
so that we can move
them forward in a way that we
understand will be able to be a living,
breathing document that can be further
revised. Vice President Glover Woods.
Thank you, President
Darlingham. And before I move forward
with the
motion, which will be somewhat
amended, I want to be
sure that I've captured
the suggested
amendments to the emotion, if you will.
So in addition
to the word
changing, again, of accountability system
and system to dashboard,
I have noted to
remove the word equally
from principle number four. I want to confirm
that I got that note correctly.
And
signal waiting, yes. Okay.
And to
for dashboard principle
one, it was
to look at
was it removing
the word well rounded or adding
Incorporating the word
well rounded. Incorporating
the word well rounded
in principle one, because I'm noting that
it is
well rounded as in the principle
currently. Okay.
So I just would like to clarify
what adjustment we want. There was a couple of comments
to that effect, and maybe it got
added right before
we got here to look
at it. So that's great.
So just really the principle
four, which we heard several
comments on.
Okay. And
again, I second that the emotion
of having our additional
conversation. We still have a lot of things
to talk about as it relates to making
sure our English learner data is accurately
reflecting the needs of our English
learners. So President
Darling-Hammond, if it's okay,
I can move forward with the motion.
All right. Okay.
I'd like to
move that we
adopt
the revised dashboard
principles with the
following amendments
to those principles.
We want to replace
the words accountability system
and system with
the word dashboard
in any of the principles where
that language
still exists. We would also
like to remove the word
equally from dashboard
principle number four
so that it reads
values each indicator.
Do I have a second
on that motion?
Second. Thank you.
Any further discussion?
I will note that there was
a caller who asked
about adding a principle
that would allow for us to evolve
the dashboard. I think we
assume that. So
we can accept
that idea in
principle, but not in the principles.
So with
that, I guess we need
a roll call vote.
President Darlin-Hammond.
Aye. Member Escobedo.
Aye. Vice President
Glover-Woods.
Yes. Member Lewis.
Yes. Member
McQuillan. Aye.
Member Olken.
Yes.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Yes. Member
Petillo-Bronson. Yes.
Member Porter.
Yes. Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Yes. Motion
carries unanimously.
All right. Thank you so
much. And thank you
Cindy, Josh, and our
friends from the Sacramento County Office of Education
for that presentation.
We are now going to
reopen item one to take
action on the preliminary report of
Actions Draft September
2022 Meeting Minutes,
the State Board of Education Screening Committee
recommendations for appointments to the Advisory
Commission on Charter Schools,
California Practitioners Advisory Group,
and the Instructional Quality Commission,
and report on our liaison assignments.
We want to do that
expeditiously so that
those who need to get to lunch can do
so. While we're waiting for
any members of the public to call in,
we've posted the public comment slide.
Do I have a motion from a board member
to approve the September 2022
State Board of Education
Draft Preliminary Report of
Action Meeting Minutes?
So moved.
Thank you. Second.
Thank you very much.
And is there
any public comment?
No, we currently
do not have anyone for public comment.
Okay, we'll now hold a roll call
vote. Brooks, please
call the roll. President Darling
Hammond. Aye.
Member Escobedo. Aye.
Vice President
Glover Woods. Yes.
Member Lewis. Yes.
Member McQuillan.
Yes. Member
Olken. Yes.
Member Roscoe Gonzalez.
Yes. Member Petillo
Brownson. Yes.
Member Porter. Yes.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes. Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Yes. Motion carries
unanimously.
Okay, we're now going to take up
the State Board Screening Committee's recommendations
for appointments to several commissions.
We need the public comment
slide back up because we're
reopening the phone line for public
comment. Thank you very much.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment
on this item may do so by calling
the telephone number and using the
access code provided on the slide that
is shown now. And while we're
waiting for any members of the public to call
in, I'll ask Vice President Glover
Woods, who chaired this year's process
with our great thanks,
to share the recommendations
from the State Board Screening Committee
regarding appointments to the Advisory
Commission on Charter Schools,
California Practitioners Advisory Group,
and the Instructional Quality
Commission.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond,
and I would like to extend my
thanks to members
Lewis and Escobedo for their time
and commitment to this process,
as well as to the CDE
and State Board of Education staff.
We had quite an opportunity to
meet and interview quite a number
of candidates for the various commissions.
A request for the applications
for new members to
the Instructional Quality Commission,
also known as the IQC, the
Advisory Commission on Charter Schools,
and the California Practitioners
Advisory Group began in August.
The
screening committee, so I'm going to start first with
the IQC or Instructional Quality
Commission
recommendations from the screening committee.
The screening committee selected
the following candidates
for the IQC for a
three-year term beginning January
1, 2023,
through December
31, 2026.
And the candidates
are as follows.
Jennifer Hicks, Assistant Superintendent
Educational Services
from Placer County Office of Education,
Janet Lanning,
Teacher, Fillmore Unified
School District,
Alicia Reigoza, Teacher
on Special Assignment from Mountain View
School District, and Erika
Cepeda, Teacher on Special
Assignment from San Bernardino City
Unified School District.
The screening committee also
recruited for the
2023-24 IQC
student member, and
we recommend Ethan Chen
for appointment to a one-year
term that will start September
1, 2023,
through June 30,
2024.
Ethan is currently a junior
at Montevista High School
in the San Ramon School District.
The next group we will
look at is the California
Practitioners Advisory Group, also
known as CPAC.
The committee met
for the members of,
oh, I'm sorry, the committee recommends
the following CPAC members
for reappointment for a
two-year term starting January 1,
2023, through December
31, 2024.
Melanie Green, Director of Continuous
Improvement and Support from San Joaquin
County Office of Education.
Ms. Green will represent
the authorized public
chartering agencies.
And Ronald Anaya,
Assistant Principal from Rockland
Unified School District.
Mr. Anaya will represent principals
and other school leaders.
The screening committee
recommends the following
individuals for appointment to
a three-year term for
the CPAC, starting January
1, 2023, through December
31, 2025.
Judy Flores,
Superintendent of the Shasta County
Office of Education.
She was selected to represent
the category of Superintendents
and other administrators.
And Kelsey Croson,
Senior Management with West Ed.
And she was selected to represent
the category of education
researchers.
The screening committee will
continue recruitment for
candidates to the CPAC
to fill the private school
representative category, and we will
bring our recommendations for the chair
and vice chair to the full board
for a vote at our January
state board meeting.
The last commission
that I'd like to share with you is
the Advisory Commission on Charter
Schools.
We recommend the following members
be reappointed for a two-year term
starting January 1,
2023, through December
31, 2024.
Erica Jones, Teacher
with the Los Angeles Unified School
District, and she will represent
the teacher category.
And Matt Taylor, Superintendent
for River Charter Schools, and
he will represent the charter schools
category.
We also recommend individuals
to be appointed to the ACCS for
a two-year term, which will start
January 1, 2023,
through December 31, 2024.
And we recommend
Todd Fennell,
County Superintendent of Schools
for Imperial County Office of Education.
He was selected to represent
the county superintendent category.
And Steve Olmos,
Superintendent of Visions and Education
Charter School, who was selected
to represent the parent or guardian
of charter school student category.
The committee will continue
recruitment for candidates
to fill the ACCS
district superintendent and teacher
categories. Their
recommendations will be brought to this board
for a vote at the January
2023 State
Board of Education meeting.
So congratulations to all of the
candidates. We look forward to working with
you on your respective commissions
and committees.
And I just need a point of
clarification. Do we need to bring a motion
forward for these or are they just
accepted as read?
I have a motion.
Okay.
All of them at once
is the way that it goes.
You don't want it individually.
One motion.
So I move that we
approve and accept all
of those. We have to have public comment
first. Oh, I'm sorry. Thank you.
Okay. That's all right.
And so I don't know if
member Lewis or member
Escobedo wants to add anything and we
appreciate their participation on the committee.
All I would like
to add is just to
commend Dr.
Cynthia Glover Woods for her
amazing grace and
organization
in performing these
interviews. It was
such an amazing
opportunity for
us to see
herculean effort reviewing
their extensive background
and interviewing.
We had so many great
candidates throughout California.
But I just wanted to commend
our vice president
for such an amazing job.
Thank you.
And I would just like to
echo those comments.
We had a very smooth
process, very smoothly.
A smooth process, an enjoyable process.
We did have a lot of great
candidates and it was just a pleasure
to meet all of the candidates
and just congratulate
them on moving forward.
Thank you so much. Are there
any public comments?
We do not have any callers on the
queue for public comment.
All right. Great.
So now can I have a motion?
I move to approve the
callers'
appointments as
read and shared to
the various commissions,
IQC, ACCS, and the
CPAC?
Terrific. Is there a second?
Second.
Thank you very much.
Brooks, can you call the roll call vote?
President Darling-Hammond.
Aye.
Member Escobedo.
Yes.
The motion carries unanimously.
Terrific, thank you.
I do want to invite our Board members to report on their liaison activities that were not
related to items on our September agenda.
I also know there are some people who have had luncheon obligations they are looking
to fulfill.
And so I will urge us to get to the high points maybe in about a minute each of our liaison
reports so that folks can be only a little bit late for their appointments.
So I'm going to start with member Escobedo.
Yes, very quick.
Last week I went to the NASB conference and presented on behalf of San Diego State but
also obviously was there presenting, you know, the state of California on partnerships with
universities and districts.
And I just want to let you know, talking about accountability, how many state representatives
came up to me and asked me questions about the dashboard.
Most of the states use a single indicator and they are fascinated with what we in California
have constructed.
So that was great.
I also attended a school with Superintendent Thurman this month, community schools who
won, they earned the implementation grant at Vista district.
And it was just great to see the beginnings, well, and further improvements on their community
schools' focus.
So that was great to see it in action.
Thank you.
Terrific.
And excellent modeling.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
I have nothing more to add, President Darley-Hammond.
All right, member Lewis.
No committee liaison report since last month, but I will say that I was able to attend the
Kern County Superintendent of Schools' equity summit and participate on a panel discussion
about putting equitable practices in action.
And it was all about students choosing to see and the power of equity in education.
So it was very enjoyable.
Member McQuillan.
Yes, lunch is calling, so I'll be brief.
We're waiting for a new date on the Joint Pathways on Career Technical Education.
We had to postpone our date this month due to trouble finding a date that works for everyone,
but looking forward to that meeting.
I want to tell everybody this is American Indian Heritage Month that starts here in
November, so keeping that in mind.
There are some wonderful model lessons in the Ethnic Studies curriculum that we passed
way back in March 2021, but reminding people there are three really good lessons in there
that could be tried out, so hoping to see that.
So thank you.
Terrific.
Thank you for that very timely reminder.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Oh, I'm sorry, Member Olken.
I'm going to be completely alphabetical here.
Hello.
I am the liaison to two different commissions.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools didn't meet this in October, so no need to
report on that.
And then also I'm the liaison for the Advisory Commission on Special Education.
And just to be super brief, I think the most exciting thing that happened at the Advisory
Commission on Special Education is Senate Bill 291 passed, which increases the size
of the commission by two, by adding two student members to the commission.
And so the, we spent a bit of time thinking about how the commission would rethink its
work to ensure that we can get the most input and leverage from having some students on
the commission.
And I think everyone's really excited about that.
And those two students will be students, the requirement is between 16 and 22 years of
age with exceptional needs.
So I think that's a really great advancement for that commission.
And that's the end of my report.
Terrific.
What a good announcement.
Member Roscoe Gonzales.
Well, I had the assessment mega items, so I think we've covered those extensively.
I just want to remind all the educators and community members that collaboration is the
key for student success and to continue that spirit of collaboration, because when we work
together, we create a better learning experience for our students.
So I just want to repeat that because I think that that will be the key going forward and
into embarking next year as we create student goals.
Terrific.
Thank you.
Member Petillo-Bronson.
Good afternoon.
And there's a couple of updates I'll share.
One is that the Department of Education has launched its UPK communications materials
which is really focused on making sure that school districts and community partners are
aware of some of the new state-funded services, funding streams, and also that there's outreach
to families so that they can avail themselves of both the expansion of universal pre-K for
threes as well as universal TK, transitional kindergarten, for fours.
I was also delighted to be able to share some of these more recent developments with the
NASB Early Learning Group online, and it is exciting to actually see that some of our
work is certainly, I think, attracting the attention of some of our state peers and other
geographies, and that there's also parallel shifts, I think, happening in other states
around the P2-3 continuum.
Lastly, I'll just flag that the Department of Social Services, which is sometimes a sort
of corresponding agency that certainly works with many of the same folks who we are focusing
on in terms of children and families, put forward its rate reform recommendations to
the early childhood workforce, particularly looking at 0-3, but also aftercare for children
0-12.
And so we are, I think, eagerly awaiting sort of to see where that moves.
And actually, the last thing I'll flag is a PPIC study that just came out, which I think
really connects to our conversation about community schools and the environments in
which children live, really celebrating what California has done and really prevented in
terms of child poverty, looking at the child poverty rates, which dramatically fell from
about 18% in 2019 to 9% in 2021.
And all of those children being both in the 0-5 space, the feeder pattern into the K-12
system, and many of those children being the 5-17 range, being able to have the wraparound
supports that enable them to show up into schools and be ready to learn.
So those wins, I think, largely were attributed to CalFresh and the EITC and Young
Child Tax Credit and just acknowledging the connection between all of our systems as we
continue to build out the whole child system of support.
Yeah, and that shift in poverty was both California-funded and federal ARPA funds, the
federal ARPA funds accounted for some of that.
You're much more generous to acknowledge the feds.
Well, and when that ended, because Build Back Better was not enacted, the poverty rates
nationally have gone back up a bit, so we've got more work to do, but we should celebrate
our successes.
Student Member Porter, your report.
Absolutely.
I'll keep it brief.
So in addition to being at the SAIP conference, I also attended two other student advocacy
conferences.
The first was in person at Portola High School, where I gave feedback along with Dr. Woods.
We actually got to be in person, which was very fun.
We gave feedback on six student proposals on financial literacy, socioeconomic inequalities
and sustainability in schools.
And I also gave a presentation to about 50 San Benito district students about student
voice on the local and statewide level and encouraging students to get involved, giving
public comment at local board meetings, creating clubs on civic advocacy, and talking to district
staff because they are the contextualized local agents.
And so that is what I've been up to, and I look forward to continuing to hear student
voice these next few months.
That's great, and it's expanding.
I love it.
Member Rodriguez.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board members and members of the public, including educators, students
and families.
Since we last met, the Commission on Teacher Credentialing has moved important work in
the areas of literacy, early childhood credentialing, and teacher data.
In literacy, the commission adopted standards and teaching performing expectations, TPEs,
to ensure teachers, including early childhood educators, are prepared to teach foundational
literacy.
I can hear you smiling through the Zoom.
It approved a mandate that all multiple-subject, single-subject, and education specialist
credentials must transition to the new standards by July 2024, and all new PK3EC credentials
must demonstrate alignment to the newly adopted literacy standards and performance expectations
in 2023.
As we all know, the way we prepare teachers is a critical step to ensure all students
learn to read and love to read.
In early childhood, the commission also adopted program preconditions, program standards,
and teaching performance expectations for the PK through three early childhood education
specialist instruction credentials.
This work is responsive to the state's master plan for early learning and care and will
be critical to staffing the state's commitment to universal transitional kindergarten.
In the area of teacher data, the commission approved a report to the legislature on the
early implementation of the California statewide assignment accountability system with the
CDE, which the CDE leveraged to publish the first-ever school site-level assignment monitoring
outcome data on DataQuest earlier this year.
Finally, the commission also approved a passing standard for the California education specialist,
NTPA, performance assessment.
Taken together, these reflect the commission's critical work to ensure that California teacher
candidates have the highest level of education, preparation, and training to meet the ever-changing
needs of all students.
So that was finally on the commission, but that is a great segue to talk a little bit
about the Yidan Prize, which supports changemakers in education to unlock a better future for
all learners.
And it is the most prestigious prize in education, and we happen to have Yidan Laureate, recipient
of the prize this year, among us, and I'd like to congratulate President Linda Darling-Hammond.
So well deserved.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, Member Rodriguez.
Member Yoshimoto-Tari.
Thank you.
So while this is my second meeting and we're finalizing my official liaison assignments, I just
wanted to say I'm looking forward to joining our colleagues at the Sacramento County and Los Angeles
County Offices of Education at the California Civic Learning Summit on November 15th, hosted by
the Californians for Civic Learning.
And this is in collaboration with the Power for Democracy Steering Committee.
And then in December, I look forward to being with our attending our California School Boards
Association End of Conference in San Diego.
Thank you.
Terrific.
And I will just add in relation to our linkage to the California Commission for Excellence in
Education, the CCEE, that they have launched the Learning Acceleration System Grant, which allows
for state funding to be used for a statewide professional learning infrastructure to support
professional development in math, ELA, and English language development.
For learning acceleration, this is being led by Santa Clara County Office of Education, San
Diego County Office of Education, and Lake County, County Office of Education, for English
language arts, and there's also a rural math collaborative.
They're developing professional learning modules covering evidence-based strategies and math
literacy and language development that will be free and accessible to educators across the state
once they're finalized in early 2023, and they held orientation meetings for their online
course writers.
Every module will include guidance on integrating universal design for learning, social-emotional
learning, and culturally sustaining pedagogy with classroom instruction for acceleration.
So that's an exciting process that's underway.
They're also hosting, they did host a Learning Acceleration System Grant professional learning
network meeting, and that will be continuing quarterly to help coordinate the efforts that
county offices and districts are undertaking.
And the rural math collaborative launched as well with its inaugural professional learning
series with the California math project.
So there's a lot going on in the state to pick up on the themes that we talked about during this
meeting for really wrapping around our students academically and in every other way to promote
accelerated learning.
And with that, I think we are at a point where we can adjourn the November 2022 meeting of the
State Board of Education at 1 10 p.m.
I wish everyone a good weekend, and those who are rushing off to lunch, a very good lunch.
Take care.
Thank you all.